A GUY GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HEARING OF APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH
- I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY IN THE STYLE IS
JUST WALKED IN WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE WILL THAT'S LIKELY
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE- SO
WE CAN GET THINGS MOVING ALONG-
I WILL CALL THIS MEETING TO
ORDER. ONCE AGAIN THERE IS A
ESTABLISH QUORUM WILL HAVE THE
SECRETARY THEN CALL THE ROLL.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE ON THEIR WAY TO
TODAY'S PUBLIC HEARING AND
CERTAINLY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WE HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS FIFTEEN
BILLS ON FILE TODAY. AND WE WILL
BE HEARING THE BILLS AND FILE
ORDER. THERE ARE THREE MEASURES
ON CONSENT THAT MEANS WE WON'T
HEAR THEM WE'LL JUST VOTE ON
THEM. BECAUSE THEY ARE. NOT
CONTROVERSIAL- AND ALL SIDES
AGREE THAT THERE ARE GOOD THINGS
THAT YOU MOVE FORWARD- WITH OF
THOSE BILLS ARE AB TWO ZERO FOUR
FOUR. AB TWO FIVE SIX SIX WITH
THE MOMENTS AB TWO EIGHT ZERO
SIX. WITH THE MOMENTS. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ARE WELCOME TO
WRITE COMMENT IN PERSON IT'S IN
PERSON THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE OR THEIR COURSE THEY
COME UP. AND SHARE THEIR OPINION
TODAY WE ARE NOT USING PHONES
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN THIS COMMITTEE
IS OPEN. WITH THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE YOUR FIRST ITEM- WHICH
IS GOING TO BE ME IT LOOKS LIKE.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS HERE- AND THAT WOULD BE
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE BY
MAIL- PATRICK O'DONNELL ME. AND
I'LL TURN THE GAVEL OVER WELL
NOT THE GALA BECAUSE WE DON'T OF
A QUORUM YET. BUT- IF WE WILL
NOW CHAIR THE COMMITTEE. YEAH.
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE PROCEED.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT AN ITEM ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU ABOUT MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I LET ME BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
HAS UNBELIEVABLY BEEN FROZEN FOR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS THAT'S THE
FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN FROZEN FOR FORTY YEARS TO
VIEW OF OUR STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS AND USE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION THAT IS FROM HOME
TO SCHOOL SCHOOL BACK HOME.
FUNDING LEVELS HAVE REMAINED
FLAT FOR EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT
SINCE THE EARLY EIGHTIES FUNDING
HAS NEVER BEEN ADJUSTED FOR
POPULATION CHANGES OR PROGRAM
GROWTH LEADING TO CASES WERE
NEARLY IDENTICAL DISTRICTS WITH
NEARLY IDENTICAL TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS RECEIVE EXTREMELY
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF STATE
FUNDING FOR THIS CRITICAL. AND
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
MANDATORY SERVICE. ADDITIONALLY
THE HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM DOES NOT
RECEIVE A COLA COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT INCREASE ANNUALLY- AS
COSTS INCREASED AS DO OTHER.
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
REIMBURSES SCHOOLS FOR LESS THAN
30% OF HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION COSTS. ON AVERAGE
WITH DOZENS OF DISTRICTS
RECEIVING LESS THAN TEN CENTS.
ON THE DOLLAR THAT'S THE DOLLAR
THEY SPEND ON HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION. CONSEQUENTLY
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTS THE LOWEST
SHARE OF ITS PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO SCHOOL THAN ANY
OTHER STATE. DENYING OUR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES. THOUGH
THE WELL DOCKET AT THE END
COMMUNITIES OF TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL- ADDITIONALLY SCHOOLS
THAT RECEIVE MINIMAL STATE
SUPPORT MUST SPEND DISTRICT
GENERAL FUND REVENUE ON
TRANSPORTATION. DIVERTING
RESOURCES OUT OF THE CLASSROOM
AB TWO NINE THREE THREE WOULD
FULLY FUND THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM
EMPOWERING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TRANSFER ALL CHILDREN. TRANSPORT
ALL CHILDREN TO AND FROM SCHOOL
BY REIMBURSING 1100% OF THEIR
TRUE EXPENSES. THE FUNDING
FORMULA REFLECTS REGIONAL COST
DIFFERENCES AND INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH IS
CRUCIAL FOR OUR STATE OF RURAL
SUBURBAN AND URBAN AREAS AB TWO
NINE THREE THREE ALSO PROVIDES
FOR FUTURE PROGRAM GROWTH AS
SCHOOLS INCREASE OUR CAPACITY.
TO MEET INCREASED DEMAND
REQUIRING MORE BUSES AND ROADS.
THESE COSTS WILL BE COVERED FOR
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND EVERY
CHILD ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ARE INANE NASH PRESIDENT OF THE
EUREKA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND BOARD ON BEHALF OF OUR AREA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO. RIGHT MAKE FADDEN
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE NEVADA
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MA
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
INDEED RENEE NASH PRESIDENT OF
THE WEEKEND SCHOOL TO SUPPORT OF
TRUSTEES AND MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF CSPA. HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF C-SPAN IS
NEARLY ONE THOUSAND MEMBER
DISTRICTS AS A SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS LEGISLATION AS
YOU KNOW THE STATE HAS STRUGGLED
IN DISTRICTS OF STRUGGLED OVER
THE PAST FORTY YEARS TO
ADEQUATELY FUND HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION. OVER THIS TIME
THE COST OF TRANSPORTATION IN
CALIFORNIA FROM GAS PRICES
QUITMAN AND STAFFING COSTS AS
WELL AS EFFORTS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS FROM DIESEL FUEL HAVE
GROWN DRAMATICALLY IT FUNDING
FOR THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM HAS
BEEN FROZEN WITHOUT A COLON. AS
A RESULT MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RECEIVE LESS THAN 30% OF FUNDING
FOR THE ACTUAL COSTS WHICH FOR
MANY DISTRICTS HAS BECOME
UNSUSTAINABLE IN EUREKA WE SPEND
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON AVERAGE
PER SPREAD STUDENT WITH NO
FEDERAL OR STATE REIMBURSEMENT.
WITH LIMITED FUNDING MANY
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
MAKE THE CRITICAL DECISION TO
REDUCE OUR TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES TO ONLY THOSE THAT ARE
FEDERALLY MANDATED MOST
DETRIMENTAL IS AND IT ADEQUATE
FUNDING HAS CREATED IN EQUITY
AND ARE STILL TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. RESULTING IN DISPARITIES
ACROSS THE STATE AS TO WHICH
STUDENTS RECEIVE A SAFE RIDE TO
AND FROM SCHOOL. THAT IS WHY
THIS LEGISLATION IS CRITICALLY
NEEDED AND WHY C. S. B. A. IS
SUCH STRONG SUPPORTER. THIS BILL
WOULD FULLY FUND THIS ESSENTIAL
PROGRAM AND ENABLE ALL STUDENTS
TO RECEIVE A SAFE RIDE TO SCHOOL
ALL STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
SAFEST WAY FOR STUDENTS TO GET
TO AND FROM SCHOOL IS ON A
SCHOOL BUS. REIMBURSING
DISTRICTS 41100% OF THEIR ACTUAL
EXPENSES. THE BILL ESTABLISHES
AN ADAPTIVE FUNDED FORMULA THAT
REFLECTS THE REGIONAL COST
DIFFERENTIALS AND FUTURE PROGRAM
GROWTH. WHICH IS CRUCIAL IN THE
STATE IS LARGE AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL ADDRESSES
THE REAL COST OF PROVIDING SCALE
AND PROVIDES A SCHOOL BUS IN
WITHOUT DEPRIVING STUDENTS OF
RESOURCES PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
IN THE CLASSROOM OR MONIES IS
NEEDED SO THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE
TO DIVERT MONEY FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. TO ADDRESS. THE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY THAT ARE GOING
TO PAY FOR TRANSPORTATION BOTH
FOR GENERAL FUND AS WELL. AS FOR
GENERAL EDUCATION AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS BECAUSE THE
ENCROACHMENT HAS BECOME
UNBEARABLE FOR MANY DISTRICTS.
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY ARE
ELIMINATING THE GENERAL
EDUCATION TRANSPORTATION WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND WE URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRETT
MCFADDEN OVER THE HONOR TO BE
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE NEVADA
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
JUST ABOUT TWENTY MILES NORTH OF
THE AUBURN AREA AND WE ARE A
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT WE SERVE
GRADES TWELVE NINE THROUGH
TWELVE AND HAVE AN ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM I'M A CONCUR
WITH THEM- THE REMARKS OF MIKE-
CALLING MISS NASH AND APPRECIATE
SOME WOMEN FOR SPONSORING THIS
THIS BILL- WE TRANSPORT WERE ONE
OF THE DISTRICTS AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTS A LITTLE OVER 50% OF
OUR STUDENTS AS A RESULT OF.
BEING IN A RURAL AREA AND I
WILL- OUR RESEARCH. EMPHASIZE MY
REMARKS IN THE AREA OF. HOW
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS
SCHOOLS AND FROM AN ACADEMIC
STANDPOINT. WHEN STUDENTS ARE
TRANSPORTED DAILY BY SCHOOL
BUSES THEY'RE SAFER- THEY ARRIVE
ON TIME THEY HAVE GREATER
ATTENDANCE. AND FROM AN EQUITY
STANDPOINT PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THAT- DUE
TO SOCIO ECONOMIC CONDITIONS OR
GEOGRAPHICALLY DRITTE
GEOGRAPHICAL CONDITIONS. I HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING TO SCHOOL ON
A DAILY BASIS AND- IS. THERE
SOME AMEND NOTED WE HAVE ONE OF
THE LOWEST- TRANSPORTATION RATES
OF ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY'RE ALSO ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH.
GETTING CARS OFF THE ROAD AND-
SAFETY BENEFITS AS WELL SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS
WOULD BE IS- THE SUPPORT WOULD
BE STATEWIDE AMONG DISTRICTS
FROM THEIR- URBAN SUBURBAN AND
RURAL ARENA SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU TO HAVE ANYONE
IN THE AUDIENCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANDREA BALL IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THREE ORGANIZATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION WHICH IS OVER A
HUNDRED ELEAZAR THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. A LOT OF THEM
VERY RURAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MEGAN BEAR WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN THE TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AS ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. A TO
CLOSE MR ARE YES THANK YOU
MANAGER JUST ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OF THE MEMBERS WHEN WE ESTABLISH
BORN. THANK YOU.
OKAY I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
IS HERE YOU MAY. SHE HAS- US
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WE LOOK
NORMAL GOODNESS CALDERON ON
CONSENT. OKAY WE HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS ARE OKAY WITH THAT WELL
I'LL GO TO A FILE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY TWO FOUR EIGHT FOUR I
MISS BONTA MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. I WOULD LIKE
TO FIRST START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AND MEN MEN'S TO
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT THAT A
CHARTERS NONPROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION BE DISSOLVED
FOR REMAINING NET ASSETS TO BE
ALLOCATED AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR ACCOMPLISHES TWO GOALS. ONE
IS THE FIRST IS THAT THE BILL
INCREASES IN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE EVENT THAT A
CHARTER SCHOOL SHUTS ITS DOORS
SECOND THIS BILL CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE AND HOW CHARTER SCHOOL
SPENDS A PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT DOLLARS. WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE RECENTLY INCREASED
STANDARDS AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOL
CLOSURES WITHOUT A CLEAR ROAD
MAP FOR HOW TO MANAGE THEM WHEN
THEY WHEN THIS DOES HAPPEN ARE
PARTICULARLY DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS EACH
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA ON AVERAGE.
AN AVERAGE OF THREE CHARTER
SCHOOLS CLOSE BETWEEN THE MONTHS
OF OCTOBER AND APRIL THESE MID
YEAR CLOSURES ARE DESTRUCTIVE
AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT NOT ONLY
STUDENTS BUT ALSO NEIGHBORHOOD
SCHOOLS MUST ACCOMMODATE THE
INFLUX OF STUDENTS BY FINDING
CLASSROOM SPACE HIRING TEACHERS
AND CLASSIFIED STAFF PURCHASING
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS AND
TRANSFERRING RECORDS MID YEAR.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
ENHANCES CHARTER SCHOOL CLOSURES
BY FIRST REQUIRING ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO UNIFORMLY REPORT
PEOPLE INFORMATION TO KALPANA
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND SECOND
TRANSFERRING ANY NET REMAINING
ASSETS AFTER CHARTER SCHOOL
CLOSES. TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN WHICH A CHARTER
SCHOOL WAS LOCATED AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR ALSO ADDRESSES
THE ISSUES OF RELATED PARTY
TRANSACTIONS CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN
ACCESS MONEY FROM THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM
FOR RENT AND LEASE
REIMBURSEMENTS ONLY HOWEVER
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE PURCHASING
PROPERTY THROUGH A RELATED THIRD
PARTY. USING DOLLARS MEANT FOR
LEASE AND RENT ASSISTANCE TO PAY
FOR THAT MORTGAGE MY BILL
ADDRESSES THIS BY. CAPPING THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF GRANT MONEY THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS MADE RECEIVED
FOR A RELATED PARTY FACILITY
REIMBURSEMENT. AT 1100% OF THE
COST OF THE FACILITY. REQUIRING
THE CHARTER SCHOOL TO MAINTAIN A
DEED RESTRICTION THAT STATES THE
RELATED PARTY FACILITY MAY ONLY
BE USED FOR PUBLIC NONSECTARIAN
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES AFTER FIFTY
PERCENT. OF ITS COST IS REPAID
THROUGH GRANT FUNDS AND THIRD
REQUIRING THAT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL. AT B. REMEMBER
REIMBURSED THAT SB SEVEN FORTY
PROGRAM FUND IF IT CLOSELY THE
CLOSES OR SELLS OR LEASES FOR
NON EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES. IT'S
RELATED PARTY FACILITY WITHIN
TEN YEARS A RECEIVING GRANTS. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR IS A
COUNT ABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND ENSURES THAT WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AS CASSIE MANCINI WITH A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN MANZINI AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION THE
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR. FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD PREVENT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THOSE MEANT FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION FROM BEING USED
BY PRIVATE CORPORATIONS TO AMASS
REAL ESTATE. THE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE SB SEVEN FORTY
PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE TO PROVIDE CHARTER
SCHOOL SERVING EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WITH ASSISTANCE
FOR FACILITIES RIGHT COSTS. TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE SCOPE OF
THIS PROGRAM SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
WELL OVER HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S BILLION WITH A B. HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS. IN RECENT YEARS SOME
LARGE CHARTER SCHOOL CHAINS HAVE
EXPLOITED LOOPHOLES IN THE
PROGRAM TO PURCHASE PROPERTY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
ANY TAX PAYER CLAIMS TO PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP OR OVERSIGHT. AND THIS
IS A HUGE PROBLEM. HERE'S HOW IT
WORKS FIRST THE CHARTER
MANAGEMENT CORPORATION CREATES A
NON PROFIT LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANY THAN THAT LOC TAKES OUT
A PRIVATE LOANS- CONDUIT REVENUE
BONTA PURCHASE A SCHOOL
FACILITY. NEXT THAT L. L. C.
LEASES THEIR FACILITY TO THE
VERY CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATOR
THAT CREATED TE LLC IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR SB. SEVEN FORTY
LEAST REIMBURSEMENT FUNDS. OVER
TIME THE LOC USES THOSE LEASE
REIMBURSEMENTS TO PAY OFF THEIR
ENTIRE LOAN. THERE IS NO LIMIT
TO THE LIFETIME AMOUNT OF SB
SEVEN FORTY PROGRAM FINDS A
SCHOOL CAN RECEIVE. SO LONG AS
IT COMPLIES WITH THE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. THAT MEANS A
SCHOOL CAN RECEIVE SB SEVEN
FORTY FUNDS IN PERPETUITY. ONCE
A LONER BOND IS FULLY REPAID THE
LOC AND EFFECTIVELY THE CHARTER
SCHOOL OPERATOR PRIVATELY OWNED
THEIR OWN SCHOOL FACILITY THAT
HAS BEEN PAID FOR ENTIRELY WITH
TAXPAYER FUNDS. NOW WHAT HAPPENS
IF THAT. WILL CLOSE AS WHAT
HAPPENS OF ORDERS REVOKED OR
DECIDES TO EXIT THE BUSINESS OF
EDUCATION. WELL THE LOC IS FREE
TO SELL THAT PROPERTY WHICH IS
ACCRUED VALUE OVER TIME. LEASE
IT TO A PRIVATE RELIGIOUS
SCHOOL. OR LET IT SIT VACANT.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM THAT SB
SEVEN FORTY DOLLARS ARE BEING
ABLE USED TO PURCHASE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS. FOR ONE THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE NO CLAIM TO
OWNERSHIP OF THESE PROPERTIES.
ALTHOUGH PROPERTIES ARE PAID FOR
ENTIRELY OR PARTIALLY. IT
DOLLARS. LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
INCLUDING THE SCHOOL'S
AUTHORIZER WILL HAVE NO SAY IN
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PROPERTY
AFTER THE SCHOOL CLOSES. THIS
MAKES FOR AN EFFICIENT SPENDING
AND BAD POLICY MAKING. AND THIS
PROGRAM'S BEEN AN EXCELLENT
EFFECTIVE WAY FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO GROW THANK YOU AT THE
TAXPAYERS EXPENSE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU. OPPOSITIONS
ARE OPPOSITION WHICH IS JUST
ABOUT- ANY I'M SORRY ANY OTHER
SUPPORT. OR GO AHEAD OF MYSELF
HERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT. FIFTY
MARK ON BEHALF OF CFTA UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANY OTHER SUPPORT
GOOD OPPOSITION OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE JOHN LINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE ARE HERE
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR- ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
FACILITIES CONTINUES TO BE A
PRIMARY CHALLENGE FOR PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE OPERATING IN THE MOST
HIGHLY IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
UNLIKE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE GET NOT
GUARANTEED FACILITIES AND DID
NOT HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDING
SOURCES DEDICATED FOR THOSE OF
US FACILITIES. BE INEQUITABLE
SITUATION REQUIRES MANY OF OUR
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS TO USE
THEIR GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDING TO
PAY FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES THE
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN PROVIDING PARTIAL
LEASE REIMBURSEMENT TO OVER FOUR
HUNDRED ELIGIBLE CHARTER SCHOOLS
OPERATING AT LEAST FACILITIES IN
HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR UNFORTUNATELY
WOULD UNNECESSARILY DAMAGE THIS
LIMITED PROGRAM. THAT IS ONE OF
OUR ONLY LIFELINES TO ADEQUATE
FACILITIES IN HIGH NEEDS AREAS
OUR GREATEST CONCERN IS THAT THE
BILL CREATES A DOUBLE STANDARD
FOR SORT FACILITIES OWNED BY NON
PROFITS AND THOSE LEAST BY
PRIVATE LAND- INVESTORS TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE PUBLIC GOOD
ABILITY OWNED BY A NON PROFIT
MUST BE HELD FOR A PUBLIC GOOD
OR SOLD FOR PUBLIC BENEFIT IF
THE FACILITY IS NO LONGER
NEEDED. CURRENT FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM REGULATIONS ALREADY
PROVIDE SCRUTINY OF AGREEMENTS
WITH AFFILIATED NONPROFITS
RENDERING AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR UNNECESSARY THE EXISTING
OPTION FOR NONPROFITS TO HOLD
TITLE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED NOT
ELIMINATED BY TARGETING
FACILITIES OWNED BY NON PROFITS
THIS BILL WOULD FAVOR READ. AND
CONTROLLED AND TERM LEASES TO
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS FOR NO
SUSTAIN PUBLIC GOOD BEYOND THE
TERMS OF THE TENDENCY CAPPING
LEASES BASED ON PURCHASE PRICE
SIGNALLERS THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT OWNERS MUST MAKE TO
RENDER A SITE. FIT FOR A SCHOOL
AND- JUST TO CLOSE I GUESS I
WOULD SAY WE ARE WE ARE ALWAYS
HAPPY TO DISCUSS COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDING ADEQUATE
FACILITIES FOR ALL PUBLIC
STUDENTS. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
BILL MOVES IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION AND- FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
YES GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. MY NAME IS ISABEL
MCDANIEL AND I AM THE PROUD
PRINCIPLE OF A SPIRE ALEXANDER
TWILIGHT COLLEGE PREPARATORY
ACADEMY HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THE
SPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS IS A
NONPROFIT ENTITY THAT OPERATES
THIRTY SIX SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SERVING OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS. OUR SCHOOL
SERVES APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY T. K. THROUGH
FIFTH GRADE STUDENTS 85% OF WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE AND
REDUCED MEALS. 30% OF WHOM ARE
MULTI LANGUAGE LEARNERS WE HAVE
A BRIGHT AND ENERGETIC AND
CARING STUDENT POPULATION THAT
IS EXCITED TO ENTER OUR
BEAUTIFUL SCHOOL BUILDING EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND I'M HERE TODAY
AWAY FROM OUR SCHOOL AWAY FROM
OUR STAFF AND FOUR HUNDRED PLUS
STUDENTS BECAUSE I AM PROFOUNDLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT
THIS BILL COULD HAVE ON THE
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS LIKE
MINE. ENSURING A SAFE AND
ADEQUATE FACILITIES IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS FACE BECAUSE WE
HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO DISTRICT
FACILITIES AND LOCAL SCHOOL
BONDS. FORTUNATELY THE S. B.
SEVEN FORTY FACILITIES GRANT
PROGRAM PROVIDES PARTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR OUR LEASE
COSTS AND ENSURES THAT MORE OF
OUR OPERATIONAL FUNDING CAN BE
SPENT IN THE CLASSROOM. WITHOUT
THIS SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS WOULD
HAVE TO INCREASE PEOPLE TO
TEACHER RATIOS OR ELIMINATE CORE
SUPPORTS SUCH AS INTERVENTION
SPECIALIST OR INSTRUCTIONAL
AIDES. SO OUR FACILITY IS OWNED
BY AFFILIATED NONPROFIT ENTITY
GOVERNED BY NONPROFIT LAWS THAT
ENSURE THAT ALL ASSETS ARE HELD%
IN PUBLIC TRUST BECAUSE OUR
LANDLORD IS ALSO A NONPROFIT
THAT IS A LINES TO OUR MISSION
WE HAVE ACCESS TO AN AFFORDABLE
HIGH QUALITY FACILITY WE ALSO
HAVE SECURITY OF A LONG TERM
AGREEMENT THAT PROVIDES FISCAL.
AND OPERATIONAL STABILITY FOR
OUR STUDENTS OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR STAFF THE PROTECTION IS
SIMPLY NOT AVAILABLE TO SCHOOLS
HE MUST LEASE THROUGH PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT LANDOWNERS. AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR IS AN
UNNECESSARY AND CONFUSING BILL
THAT WOULD FUNCTION ELIMINATE
THE OPTION FOR PUBLICLY
TRANSPARENT AND PUBLICLY
BENEFICIAL LEASE AGREEMENTS TO
CONTINUE INSTEAD IT WOULD
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SCHOOLS LIKE OURS TO BE IN
UNPREDICTABLE PROFIT DRIVEN
SITUATION WITH LAND OWNERS THAT
WOULD NOT OFFER ANY LASTING
BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC. ALL
STUDENTS DESERVE THE RIGHT TO A
HIGH QUALITY FUNCTIONAL STABLE
SCHOOL FACILITY THEREFORE WE
REQUEST THAT YOU REJECT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU I TO
GET DEL WHAT WORDS I DIDN'T STAY
THE BEING HERE IS TO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH ARE- SO WITH
THAT I IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NO OTHER OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IN THE ROOM BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- I JUST WANNA SAY MISS
BONTA APPRECIATE YOUR BILL. NOT
TRYING TO SHUT DOWN ANY SCHOOL.
AND THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
FACILITY DOLLARS AND UP IN. THE
SERVER PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN.
RIGHT IT'S NOT ABOUT HELPING A
PRIVATE INVESTOR AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS A LOOPHOLE. THAT ALLOWS
PRIVATE INVESTORS. THE END UP
OWNING BUILDINGS THAT WERE
BOUGHT WITH PUBLIC DOLLARS AND
THAT SIMPLY. WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO FIX HERE TODAY SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILLS OR ANY
OTHER COMMENTS READY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MR BENNETT
AND MR BENNETT BEFORE WE COULD
BE ESTABLISH A QUORUM. O'DONNELL
HERE ADULT PRESENT VALLEY.
VALLEY PRESENT BENNETT HERE
SENATE PRESIDENT CHEN LEAVE
MCCARTY MCCARTY PRESENT
QUIRK-SILVA. SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM THE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED MISTER BENNETT HAD
SOME COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR BOTH
SIDES HERE- FOR THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ADVOCATES- DO YOU- DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THERE. IS ANY MERIT
TO THE ARGUMENT THAT SOME
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE GOING BEYOND
. THE PURCHASE PRICE OF THE
SCHOOL AND I BUT I RECOGNIZE
THAT. YOU HAVE BOTH THE PURCHASE
PRICE I'M NOT THE PURCHASE PRICE
BUT YOU HAVE THE FACILITY ITSELF
BUT YOU LSO HAVE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE TO MAKE- SO IF
THOSE IMPROVEMENTS AND THE
FACILITY ARE PAID FOR- DO YOU
FEELS THAT THERE'S COULD SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE REIMBURSED MUCH
BEYOND THAT. BEING OUT OF SCHOOL
FIGHTS- FACILITIES MAINTENANCE
IS AN NGOING PROCESS IT WILL
NEVER END EVERY YEAR I'M TELLING
MY DAD FACILITIES MANAGER PLEASE
CAN WE GET THE BLACKTOP REPAVE
CAN WE FIX THE GIRLS RESTROOMS
CAN. THERE IT'S NEVER ENDING
PROCESS SO IF THESE FUNDS ARE
INTENDED TO SUPPORT THE UPKEEP
OF FACILITIES AS WELL AS THE
PURPOSE PURCHASE THEN IT WOULD
BE CONSISTENT AND ONGOING. AND I
WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE
SEVEN FORTY PROGRAM- IS A
PARTIAL LEASE PROGRAM THAT
FOCUSES FIRST ON LEASES AND
THEN. OTHER COSTS AND SO THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE.
IT'S PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
PARTIAL LEASE REIMBURSEMENTS
WERE NOT GETTING REIMBURSED
FULLY FOR THE- FOR THE FACILITY
RIGHT AND SO- THEY'RE STILL
MONEY COMING OUT OF THE GENERAL
OPERATING. BUDGETS THIS THIS
PROGRAM JUST TAKES SOME RELIEF.
AWAY FROM THE GENERAL OPERATING
EXPENSE AND HELPS US IN IN A
LITTLE A FEW DIFFERENT WAYS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE. THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE LIKE DISTRICTS
STILL AND FOR THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL- IS WHEN WE IDENTIFY A
100% TO REMAINA 100% OF THE
ORIGINAL COST OF THE BUILDING.
OR DO WE HAVE IS THERE ANY
PROVISION IN THERE FOR- THE COST
OF IMPROVEMENTS MADE TO THE
BUILDING MODIFICATIONS
ARCHITECTURAL CHANGES EXCEPT.
YOU KNOW THAT MY WITNESS ANSWER
THAT NO FOLLOW UP. YEAH THE BILL
ALLOWS FOR ON THAT COST
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENTS IT DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THOSE IF. THE 1100%
THRESHOLD IS ALREADY BEEN
REACHED. SO THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
COULD STILL APPLY FOR PROGRAM
FUNDS FOR FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENTS AND THEN HOW ABOUT
MAINTENANCE OF THE FACILITY AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE FACILITY.
THEY CAN ALSO APPLY FOR THAT. I
BELIEVE. THAT IS WHAT THE
CURRENT WHATEVER THE CURRENT
PROGRAM REGULATIONS ALLOW THOSE
FUNDS TO BE SPENT ON YES. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THAT CLEAR
FASHION TAKES AND IS MONEY CLEAR
TO THE COMMITTEE. MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH- SB SEVEN
FORTY THROUGH WHICH- CHARTER
SCHOOLS CAN RECEIVE FACILITY
FUNNY. THEY CAN BE PART OF A CAN
PARTICIPATE THE STATE SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM AS WELL
THERE'S MONEY. FOR THEM TO DO
THAT AS WELL AS ONE MAKE THAT
CLEAR DOESN'T LIKE THE ONLY
AVENUE FOR THEM TO GET MONEY
THERE ARE OTHER AVENUES TO GET
MONEY THE CONCERN HERE. IS WHEN
THESE FACILITIES- AND UP IN
PRIVATE HANDS A CHARTER SCHOOL
CLOSES WHAT HAPPENS. RIGHT AND
THEY WERE PURCHASED WITH PUBLIC
MONEY. THAT THAT THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT MISS BONTA. IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE. PUBLIC
DOLLARS A PUBLIC PROPERTY NOT
PUBLIC DOLLARS BECOMING PRIVATE
PROPERTY. RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
THAT WISH TO COMMENT- WITH THAT-
DO DO WE HAVE A MOTION. IT'S
REMOVED IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY AGAIN
OR REITERATE THAT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM
REMAINS FULLY INTACT AT THERE
ISN'T A QUESTION ABOUT CHANGING
ANY KIND OF ELIGIBILITY.
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AT ALL-
THIS LEGISLATION AT ALL IT IS
REALLY TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
UNFORTUNATE EVENT WHEN A CHARTER
SCHOOL CLOSES AND BE HAVING
ABSOLUTE CLARITY THAT THE
DOLLARS ASSOCIATED WITH. AT THE
SB SEVEN FORTY GRANT PROGRAM I
AND AT REALLY COME BACK INTO THE
PUBLIC SECTOR AND STAY IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR I JUST WANT TO
OFFER BY WAY OF EXAMPLE TO IT TO
JUST ELUCIDATE WHAT WE ARE
REALLY TRYING TO PREVENT FROM
HAPPENING. AT LEAST ALLIANCE
ALICE AT EXTRA COLLEGE READY
HIGH SCHOOL CLOSED THE CMO
ALLIANCE PURCHASED IT IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN FOR THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. FROM THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR. IN
ACADEMIC YEAR ALLIANCE RECEIVED
ABOUT ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SB SEVEN FORTY
PROGRAM FUNDS FOR LEASE
REIMBURSEMENTS IT IS NOW LISTED
FOR SALE WITH AN ASKING PRICE OF
NINE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
. THEREFORE SIMPLY HANGING ON A
PRIOR HANGING OTO A PROPERTY BY
SIMPLY HANG ON TO THIS PROPERTY
ALLIANCE WAS ABLE TO NET NEARLY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN. PROFIT
AT THIS IS UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN OUT
WITH SB SEVEN FORTY DOLLARS WE
WANT THOSE DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
COME BACK INTO OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS AND TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS. AND THERE IS A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN- AT PRIVATE
ACTORS AND A FULL PUBLIC
ENTITIES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT-
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT S.
AS AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
SEEKS TO STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT OF
CHARTER SCHOOL CLOSURES
SPECIFICALLY. AND AT PROPERTY
TRANSACTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. AT THAT OUR TAX BASS BINS
IN PUBLIC EDUCATION. AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS REMAIN ACCESSIBLE TO
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS. AT THAT THAT
COMMITTEE AT MOVES AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA FOR YOUR
CLOSER WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM ONE AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. DONALD HI DONALD
I DALLI. DALLI KNOW BENNETT.
BENNETT I CHEN LEAVE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY II QUIRK-SILVA. ISRAEL
ALSO IT IS ON CALL THANK YOU FOR
THAT WERE GONNA GO TO MR CHENEY
HAD A PREVIOUS ARRANGEMENT ARE
MISTER GARCIA IS NEXT I KNOW
HE'S SITTING OUT THERE. JOHNNY
THE BIT TO GET UP HERE- BUT MR
TANG GO AHEAD YOU MISTER TEAM
HAS- A. B. C. R. OF OUR FILE
ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT. AB NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY A PRETTY
HISTORIC BILL HE'S GOING TO
PRESENT HERE YOU DON'T HEAR
BILLS LIKE THIS EVERY DAY THE
STATE LEGISLATOR SO PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS BILL. AS BILL
IS A BIG DEAL IT. MAY BE MUCH
GREATER BY YOUR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WERE HAPPY TO
TAKE SO. WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
HELP ON THE BILL- THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WAS
PASSED IN PUT IN PLACE MY VERY
FIRST YEAR LEGISLATURE. IT'S WHY
TIME THAT WE REFORM IT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT IT.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN OUR STATE BUDGET
AND OF COURSE THE ALLOCATION FOR
PROP NINETY EIGHT. SO THIS BILL
DOES A COUPLE THINGS ONE IT ADDS
HOMELESSNESS AS A CATEGORY. TO
OUR L. SUPER FORMULA. SO PEOPLE
STILL. NOW CAN. TOWARD THIS CLUB
IS THE UP WITH ARE HOMELESS TO
SOMEBODY'S WERE HOME DISTRICTS
HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY TAKE CARE OF
THEM THEY NEED TO BE SOURCES TO
GO DO THAT- OUR POVERTY LEVEL IS
WAY TOO LOW WE LOOK AT OF A
THRESHOLD OF TWO HUNDRED AND 50%
OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WE'RE
MOVING OUR POVERTY LEVEL UP TO
THE CAL POLY LEVEL WHICH WOULD
ENCOMPASS MORE. CALIFORNIANS
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE KNOW THAT
EVERY DISTRICTS NEEDS MONEY
ACROSS THE BOARD WE ARE WE ARE
PUSHING FOR A BASE INCREASE ARE
OFF THE BOARD EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL DISTRICT A 15% AS OF THE
YEAR SUBURBAN- THE ROOM. EVERY
YOU GET FIFTEEN INCREASE.
DISPLACING HE LAST WEEK. WE ARE
AGREEING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN CREATING A THREE
YEAR RUNNING AVERAGE FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT FUNDING SO. MOVING AWAY
FROM THE HOLD HARMLESS BUT THIS
ALLOWS A SOFTER LANDING. FOR
DISTRICTS. VERY CUTE SO MAKE
SURE THE DISTRICTS WITH A HIGH
POPULATION OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS POPULATION OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS WILL REALLY. BE GIVEN
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED BUT IN
PARTICULAR THIS IS A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT
IN OUR STATE NEEDS HELP AND
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THAT
FIFTEEN PERCENT. WHICH THEY'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR. AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT WE HAVE
JENNIFER BAKER HERE- KALISTO
SCALLOP WAS THE- WHAT. PRESS
THAT BUTTON THERE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
BAKER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT
PROBABLY USE THAT REDEFINING THE
REDEFINITION OF CHILD POVERTY IN
A MORE ACCURATE WAY AS PROPOSED
IN THIS MEASURE WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT HAVE HIGH NUMBERS OF
CHILDREN FACING POVERTY AND THAT
ARE HOMELESS IN STUDENTS WITH
ADDITIONAL NEEDS SHOULD BE
PROVIDED WITH THE RESOURCES.
THEY TRULY NEED TO SUCCEED WHICH
ALL POVERTY ON THE RISE
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS OF
COLOR PORTENTS OF THE SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
PROBABLY APPRECIATES THE STAFF
ANALYSIS WHICH KNOWS WHAT THE
ANNUAL CHILDREN IN CHILDREN IN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY YOUNG. ARE
LIKELY. ALREADY A ONE IN FIVE
LATINO ARE LIVING IN POVERTY
SEVENTEEN POINT 4% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS FOURTEEN POINT 5% OF
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AS WELL AS TWELVE
POINT 1% OF OUR CUT CATION
STUDENTS ALL STUDENTS DESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED
DESPITE HOUSING STATUS THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE WILL PROVIDE
THAT SUPPORT NOT URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY.
THANK YOU TO YOUR NEXT WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. NO THERE'S NO THE
WITNESSES SUPPORT- OKAY ARE
THERE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT. THE WE HAVE ONE NOW.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE NOT I MEAN
IT'S NOTHING ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU. A SCENE NO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT- IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OF. ARE
COMING SUPPORT SUPPORT YEAH ONE
UP HERE. CRISTINA HELLO ETCETERA
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU WITH THAT ANY
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE CIVIL.
SEEING OPPOSITION WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION THIS BILL BECAUSE
THIS IS A GREAT BILL. EVERY SAVE
A LOT- BUT 15% TO THE BASE IS
BEYOND HISTORIC BEYOND HISTORIC
AND THAT CAN TAKE CARE OF
WRITING NEEDS IN OUR SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA- I OFTEN TALK
ABOUT CLASS SIZE RIGHT. A SUB
OVER THE FALL IN THE CLASSROOM
AND THE MAGIC THAT HAPPENS IN A
MIDDLE SCHOOL CLASSROOM THERE'S
ONLY TWENTY FOUR KIDS VERSUS
THERE. IS BIG RIDE IT CHANGES
THE TONE OF THE SCHOOL DAY WHEN
CLASSROOM THE COMPETITIONS A
LITTLE BIT LASSEN. IS JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE PLEASANT FOR
BRADY REASONS RIGHT WITH OUR
LOVELY MIDDLE SCHOOLERS BUT THIS
CAN HELP LOWER CLASS SIZES IT
CAN HELP. ADDS CALPERS TO A
SCHOOL. THIS IS A BIG BIG DEAL
THIS FIFTEEN PERCENT. YOU'RE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT PROPOSAL
WHICH REALLY CREATES A SLOPE. AS
CALIPH AS THE CALIFORNIA
POPULATION GOES DOWN THE SCHOOL
AGE POPULATION GOES DOWN. WE
WERE FACING A CLIFF. WE'RE
DISTRICTS SUDDENLY WHATEVER DROP
WHERE THEY WOULDN'T HAVE. DAHLE
AND THIS CREATES A SLOPE. THIS
CREATES A SLOPE- SO THIS IS A
HUGE BILL. IT'S MONSTROUS IS
TREMENDOUSLY IMPACTFUL. FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
SO I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
WORKING WITH ME WITH US. ON ON
THIS BILL. AND I THINK IT IT
SPEAKS VOLUMES TO WHAT NEEDED
YOU KNOW THE MONEY IS THERE AND
A LOT OF YEARS THE MONEY IS NOT
THERE. THIS YEAR THE MONEY IS
THERE AND IT NEEDS TO GO. TO THE
CLASSROOM. CLR EFFORTS AROUND
THE CAPITOL DRIVE IT AWAY FROM
THE CLASSROOM. THIS MONEY NEEDS
TO GO INTO THE CLASSROOM. NOT
ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE WANT IT'S
ABOUT WHAT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
NEED A SORT. THANK YOU NOT.
RETAIN UP I'M- A- AT FIFTEEN
TIMES PROBABLY FIFTEEN DIFFERENT
WAYS BUT WITH THAT MISS BENNETT
. THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I CERTAINLY DO APPRECIATE THE
WHO STARK SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK QUESTIONS
FOR YOU MISTER KING- NUMBER ONE
OF. THE POVERTY LINE. IN MY
NOTES REFER TO A SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT THAT
POVERTY LINE'S GOING TO BE
CONSTANTLY ADJUSTED IS IT GOING
TO STAY WITH A- WITH A WITH A
CAL. DEFINITION AS WELL MAKE
SURE THERE IS THERE IS SOME KIND
OF- I MISSPOKE SO HE'S OUT SO
INSTEAD OF GOING FROM THE
FEDERAL SCHOOLS MEAL THRESHOLD.
YOUR NUMBERS RIGHT WE ARE DOING.
A CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY LEVEL
WHICH IS TWO HUNDRED AND 50% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY WHICH IS ABOUT
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND FOR FAMILY
PORTRAITS BUT AND THAT WILL
CONSTANTLY ADJUST AS TO. THAT
STEVE AS A FORM YES GREAT I
CHECK IT OUT SECOND ISSUE JUST
AFTER WORKING IN SCHOOLS FOR A
LONG TIME. THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS. IS- IN IN THIS
POPULATION. IS TRANSIENT AND-
I'M JUST WORRIED ABOUT. THE THIS
IS A SENSE OF UNFAIRNESS THAT
SOME PEOPLE WILL. WILL
POTENTIALLY HAVE IF THEY FEEL
LIKE SOME SCHOOL. AS SOON AS
THEY FIND OUT SOMEBODY'S
HOMELESS THEY KEEP THEM IN THAT
CATEGORY FOR THE NEXT. FOUR FIVE
YEARS WITHOUT RECHECKING- CAN
YOU HELP ME WITH. WHAT ARE THE
SAFEGUARDS TO A AND WHAT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESS. AND WHETHER SAFEGUARDS
TO MAKE SURE THE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ALL. HANDLING IT
FAIRLY SO THAT NO ONE DISTRICT
IS. TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE OTHERS NO I
THINK IT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO-
THE DEFINITION OF HOMELESSNESS
MATCHES ARE THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION IF YOU'VE A BETTER
DEFINITION WERE ALL YEARS HAPPY
TO. HAPPY TO GET YOUR GUIDANCE
ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. THE
OTHER PIECES MOST HOMELESS
CHILDREN WILL BECOME FREE COMING
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES- IN
ORIGINAL ITERATION BILL WAS ON
DUPLICATING ALL THESE THINGS BUT
SINCE THEY'RE ALL- DUPLICATED.
IT'S ALMOST THERE THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE FOR A DISTRICT. TO
KEEP THAT CHILD HOMELESS- IF
THEY COME FROM A LOWER INCOME
FAMILY THERE WE CAN BE COUNTED
IN THAT POT THERE WE CAN GET
MONEY FOR THAT POT- I THINK WITH
THIS WILL ADD TO A DISTRICT IS A
FOR. ABOVE ALL. I REALLY DON'T
THINK MUCH INCENTIVE- ANY THIS
TO YOUR KEEP TOUCH OUT ALMOST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
CONGRATULATIONS GREAT A GOOD
BILL MISTER MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MISS- DONALD- I DON'T HAVE MUCH
OF A VOICE TODAY SOME OF THE-
KEEP QUITE AS MUCH AS I CAN BUT
I MAY JOIN AUTHOR OF THIS BILL-
THIS IS A RIGHT ON THE RIGHT
POLICY I THINK THAT PATRICK. HAD
A LOVE FOR THIS IN HIS
DESCRIPTION OF THE ALLOWED MR
O'DONNELL CAN WE SAVE SOME OF
THAT FOR THE OTHER BILLS. IF
THEY'RE GOOD. OKAY WHILE THE
OTHER HALF GOOD AS THIS ONE
OKAY. WELL HALF OF THE TITLE ON
THERE IS MY NAME SO I'LL TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF. THAT APPRECIATION
BUT WE'RE WORKING ON THIS ALONG
WITH YOU IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR TWO REASONS ONE. THERE ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE TOO
MANY STUDENTS ARE LEFT BEHIND
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE THIS ELSE IF
THAT POLICY- ALIVE THE DISTRICTS
WITH CONCENTRATIONS OF THESE
CATEGORIES. ARE STILL LEFT
BEHIND STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING
AND SOME WOULD SAY WHY DON'T
GET. MY SHARE OVER HERE FROM THE
WEALTHY OUR COMMUNITY AND- THIS
PARTICULAR HOUSE SAID WE DON'T
HAVE THEIR CHALLENGES. YOU KNOW
YOU WANT TO TAKE THEIR
CHALLENGES. AND THEN THEN GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT AND EVEN WITH
ALL THE SOURCES- STUDENTS ARE
STILL. LEFT BEHIND AND SO I
THINK CHANGING THE DATE. GORIES
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND THEN
ALSO AS YOU NOTED- THIS FOCUSES
ON THE BAYSIDE YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING A LOT ABOUT WITH
INFLATION. MANDATORY COSTS AND
PURRS AND STIRS COSTS THAT
REALLY THE INCREASES NORTH OF
10% AND DOESN'T EQUATE TO WHAT
WE HAVE IN THERE ARE COLLAPSE.
THAT'S HOW WE SEE CHALLENGES.
FACING OUR EMPLOYEES OUR
EDUCATORS LIVING WAGES THAT'S
WHY WE SEE- STRIVE ALONG-
THROUGHOUT DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MINE RIGHT HERE
IN MY HOMETOWN- SO THIS. FOCUSES
ON PUTTING RESOURCES TO. OTHER
BASE AND WE WILL DO ALL THAT WE
CAN IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO
MIRROR. THIS POLICY BUT THIS
PUTS IT. SHE GOT BORED SO THANK
YOU. THANK GOD I JUST WANT TO
KNOW MISTER MCCARTY HARD WORK ON
THE BUDGETS UP TO ON THIS VERY
TOPIC AS WELL AND I WANT TO
PUSH. IT ALL HE DOES IS THERE
ANY. MEMBERS OF ANY OTHER
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THE VICE
CHAIRMAN'S DOLLY I KNOW YOU WANT
TO SPEAK ON THIS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THIS IS A GREAT BILL. IN
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC ASSUMING
WAS SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND TEACHERS THIS IS OING TO
PROVIDE A LOT OF STILL STABILITY
MOVING FORWARD. FINANCIALLY AND
DEALER FOR MY SMALLER SCHOOLS.
THEY'RE GONNA ESPECIALLY
WESTERNERS AND- EVERYTHING THAT
FACES THEM THIS IS GREAT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I THINK UP THE FLOOD
THINKING IN PARTICULAR WITH OUR
FOOD WITH OUR POVERTY LEVEL
BEING RATES IT'S GOING TO REALLY
IMPACT THE NORTHERN PART OF OUR
STATE. SOMETIMES YOU YOU KNOW
THIS- WE HEAR FROM MR GALLAGHER
AS WELL IF SOME THE COMMUNITIES
ARE KIND OF RIGHT IN BETWEEN
THERE ON THE BUBBLE I THINK THIS
WILL. BRING ALL THOSE
COMMUNITIES KIND OF INTO THE
PROPERLY CATEGORIZED THE
STRUGGLE THAT THERE HAVE. GREAT
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANT TO
ALSO KNOW THE HARDWORKING MISTER
MURATSUCHI. ON THIS EFFORT. AND
HE HAS BROUGHT TO BE A CONCERN
WITH A THREE YEAR- ROLLING
AVERAGE SHOULD APPLY. TO THIS
YEAR GIVEN THE ADA. ATTENDANCE
NOT NECESSARILY ENROLLMENT WAS
DOWN DURING PARTS OF THE YEAR
AND THAT IS GOAL TO REALLY
GOING. TO SCHOOL FINANCES AND
THAT'S A CONVERSATION WILL HAVE
GOING FORWARD. SO WITH THAT I
JUST I AGAIN WANT TO COMMENT HOW
IMPORTANT. AND HISTORIC THIS IS.
AND THIS IS A GOOD THING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS AND ACTUALLY A
GOOD THING FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. WITH THE LARGEST CLASS
SIZES IN THE NATION. YOU WANNA
TALK ABOUT STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH. LAWYER CLASS SIZES
TEACHER MENTAL HEALTH. LOWER
CLASS SIZES WHAT NEW TEACHERS IN
THE DOOR WANT TO KEEP THEM.
ASSIZES ONCE STUDENTS MORE
COUNSELORS IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS THAT THIS- THIS FIFTEEN
PERCENT. COULD SUPPORT AT THE
SCHOOL SITE IN THE CLASSROOM SO
THANK YOU MISTER TÍNH YOU MAY
CLOSE- WE WHAT WE KNOW THAT THE
THIS IS YOUR LAST TERM YOU CAN
BE RETURNING TO THE CLASSROOM.
SO WE HOPE THAT WHEN YOU GET
BACK TO THE CLASSROOM YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THAT CLASS SIZE
REDUCTION YOU CAN SEE THOSE
RESOURCES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS BILL- WE THINK
IT'S ABOUT TIME. LIKE YOU SAID.
TO MAKES IT GETS TO BATHROOM
WITHOUT RESPECT RUSSIA RIGHT AND
WHAT WE'RE TALK ABOUT ONGOING
MONEY IS ONE TIME MONEY BOB YOU
THINK YOU CAN EMBED THAT INTO
ONGOING EXPENSES NOT A ONE TIME
MONEY ONE TIME EXPENSE IS
ONGOING MONEY WILL BE BACK SO WE
CAN COUNT ON IT WE CAN SCORED A
NINETY EIGHT WITH THAT- MISTER.
MISTER ONE MAY COME. BUT YOU
MUST NOT WELL I'D LIKE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR I THINK I MENTIONED
THAT- AND I WILL SECOND ABOUT
ABOUT THAT- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. CHAU JEROD LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL ALSO IF IT'S
PREVENT IT WHICH IS A CO AUTHOR
SAID WHY. YES DAWALY. YEAH YES
JUST EVERYBODY HAPPY ABSOLUTE.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB AT NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ADOPT HI DONNA HI
DALLI DALLI I'VE DONE IT. SENATE
AYE CHAN CAN I LEAVE MCCARTY.
RTI QUIRK-SILVA. THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT THANK YOU
SO THANK YOU- MR TING. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE THROUGH AB.
EIGHTEEN FIVE. SIERRA OR CITY
MAY COME FOR TO PROCEED WHEN
READY THAT'S FILE ITEM THREE.
WHATEVER A LOT MAYBE HOPEFULLY.
JUST GET THAT THING. MISTER
CHAIR IN THE REAL WORLD REALITY
I'M HERE THAT HE SUCKS AND I WE
GOT A WE GOTTA LET MR FELTING GO
BEFORE ALL OF US. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK I WAS THINKING WE ARE
THAT THE WELL DONALD ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- TO YOUR TEAM WHO PUT
TOGETHER THE ANALYSIS AND
AMENDMENTS TO MOVE THIS. POLICY
FORWARD I'LL JUMP STRAIGHT IN
IT'S A AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE
WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENTS. THAT BOLSTER
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS FOR A BETTER
AND RELIABLE SUPPLY. OF
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS AND MINIMIZE
CLASSROOM DISRUPTIONS. WITH ME
IS JEFF WALKER CHIEF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS OFFICER FOR ROOMS LIKE
THE OFFICE. OF EDUCATION AND WE
ARE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
GIVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS JEFF AKA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOLS THE PLEASURE TO BE HERE
THIS AFTERNOON TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE MISTER CHAIR YOU BATES UP
LUCIEN'S EARLIER TO YOUR
EXPERIENCE AS A SUBSTITUTE
DURING. I WAS REALLY A CUTE A
DURING THE FALL MONTHS AND AFTER
THE WINTER BREAK TO THE POINT
WHERE A RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WAS DEPLOYING ABOUT
SIX DOZEN CERTIFICATED STAFF
THAT WORK AT OUR COE OUT TO OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON MONDAYS AND
FRIDAYS TO HELP ALLEVIATE THE
SHORTAGES UP THAT WAS NOT MUCH
MORE THAN A STOP GAP MEASURE.
YOU KNOW SET. THE IPAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH A NUMBER OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO MIGHT SHOW UP
IN A HIGH SCHOOL CHEMISTRY CLASS
BEING EXPECTED WITH OPPOSITION
AND TO YES THE SUIT ON A FRIDAY
AND YOU CAN PROBABLY IMAGINE HOW
WELL THAT WENT. IT'S DEFINITELY
A PROBLEM. AND THAT THE IS WHAT
DO WE DO ABOUT IT OF WHAT WE
FIND APPEALING ABOUT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S BILL IS
THAT IT'S FOCUSED ON LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL SOLUTIONS
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THE ISSUES
THAT ARE FACING TEMECULA AND
MURRIETA IN THE SOUTH PART OF
OUR CAMPAIGN WE'RE GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THOSE OF OUR
DESK DISTRICTS LIKE. HE TO. TIME
TO. LAW S. AND DEVELOP. PROGRAMS
THAT ADDRESS THOSE LOCAL ISSUES
WE FIND VERY APPEALING. OF
COURSE WE'RE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND MANY OTHER
EFFORTS THIS YEAR TO ALLEVIATE
TEACHER SHORTAGES AND STAFF
SHORTAGES. YOUR COMMITTEE HAS
APPROVED A NUMBER OF BILLS WILL
SOON BE SUPPORTING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY'S BILL THAT'S
LOOKING AT YOUR GRADE
UNDERGRADUATE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS. THAT WE
SEE THIS SUBSTITUTE P. INCREASE
IMPORTANT. REASON FOR POLICE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR
THEIR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE IMPERIAL COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND SUPPORT
THE ANCILLARY THANKS THANK YOU
SEE NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEE NO
OPPOSITION OVER ANY OF OUR
CULTURALLY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. I'LL JUST COMMENT AS I SHARED
MY EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM
THIS FALL AS A SUB YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T GET A CONFERENCE HERE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO COVER.
ANOTHER CLASS BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH SUBS RIGHT AND
TEACHERS ARE HAVING THE SAME
EXPERIENCE WHERE IN THEIR
CONFERENCE PERIODS ARE EATEN UP
BY COVERING ANOTHER CLASS SO
THIS IS A REBEL DINING- AND WE
NEED. FOR APPRECIATE THE
HIGHLIGHTING OF LOCAL SOLUTIONS.
STATE SUPPORT. FOR LOCALS
FINDING SOLUTIONS TO LOCAL
PROBLEMS AND PRECIADO. SO WITH
THAT YOU MAY. CLOSE THANK YOU
MISS CHAIRED WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE
- AND SECOND I MISS DOLLY I. AND
WE HAVE CLOSED A MOTION AND A
SECOND YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE FILE ITEM THREE AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI THE
DONALD I DOUBT SALII SENATE.
CHEN CHEN I LEAVE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY II QUIRK-SILVA OR BOTH
IT HAS FOR VOTERS OUT MISTER C.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO MISTER GIBSON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOR MISTER GIBSON. AND
I'M GONNA TURN THE- YOU KNOW
WHAT IN FACT I DIDN'T. PUT THAT
DOWN EARLIER O THERE WE GO.
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. I'M GOING
TO GIVE MISTER THE GAVEL HERE I
NEED TO. LEAVE FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU ALLOW ME
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO
ECSTATIC A SCHOOL SAFETY PILOT
PROGRAM AND AGAIN I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE A SCHOOL SAFETY PILOT
PROGRAM AND DESIGNATE A TRAINED.
ON DE ESCALATION SPECIALISTS TO
RESPOND TO THE STUDENTS
DISRUPTION BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF OF
WITH THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL I
WILL BE RESPECTFULLY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS AS DISCUSSED IN
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL. THE DE
ESCALATION SPECIALISTS DESCRIBED
IN THIS BILL WOULD BE A STAFF
MEMBER WHO DOES NOT CARRY A
WEAPON. BUT ARE SKILLED IN
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE CONFLICT
RESOLUTENESS ALEUTIAN AND OTHER
TECHNIQUES- THAT MAY BE USED TO
RE DIRECT STUDENTS WHEN THERE IS
A CONFLICT THAT MAY ARISE NOW
MORE THAN EVER OUR FOCUS SHOULD
BE EYEING TO SUPPORT OUR TROOPS
THE SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH
OF OUR STUDENTS RECENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DATA
SHOWS THAT A REFERRALS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SCHOOL RELATED
ARRESTS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
STUDENTS HAVE ALSO SHOWN THE DE
ESCALATION STRATEGIES. USING
DOES NOT PREVENT A CURRENT
CRISIS BUT OVER TIME CAN HELP
PREVENT- INTENTIONAL BEHAVIOR
THAT MAY SPILL INTO SOME KIND OF
CONFLICT IT IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
THE ESCALATION- THAT EXISTS
AMONG FIGHTS AND CONFLICTS BUT
EXT OUT OF SYNC A POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS ABSOLUTELY VITALLY
IMPORTANT. TO BE CLEAR THIS IS
NOT A NEW IDEAL. WE HAVE SEEN
EARLY SUCCESS WITH CAMPUSES-
THAT INCLUDE THE ESCALATION
SPECIALIST AND OTHER CONFLICT
RESOLUTION STRATEGIES. BUT WE
HAVE BUT WE WANT TO GIVE ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS ON THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPLORE DIFFERENT OPTIONS LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVES AS A
IMPORTANT AND VITAL ROLE AND I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE. THEIR ROLE
IS VERY VITAL AND IMPORTANT
KEEPING OUR SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS
SAFE AND SECURE HOWEVER. WHEN IT
COMES TO HELPING STUDENTS DURING
A CRISIS THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
A PROACTIVE APPROACH THAT
MITIGATES THESE CRISIS ADDRESS
DISRUPTIVE STUDENTS BEHAVIOR AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY HELP CREATES A
HIGH LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
POSSIBLE FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
THIS BILL WOULD NOT. REPLACE THE
ESCALATION- SPECIALLY OFFICERS
HOWEVER THIS IS A THOUGHTFUL
MEASURE- THAT WE BELIEVE BECAUSE
THAT IT HAS BEEN TRIED BEFORE
THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY IN
HELPING SOME OF THE ISSUES ON
OUR CAMPUS- WITH ME TO PROVIDE A
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL- IS-
BROOKLEY WILLIAMS THE SENIOR
ADVISER. FOR SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TO TONY
THURMOND. I THINK IT'S IT WOULD
OF. HERE NOW ARE AT ODDS. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MURS I'M
BERKELEY WILLIAM SENIOR ADVISER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT-
CATION AND I'M TESTIFYING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
WHO IS THE SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
SCHOOL VIOLENCE AND CONFLICTS
THESE ISSUES CONTINUE TO BE A
PROBLEM FOR OUR SCHOOLS. OVER
JUST THE PAST FEW MONTHS I'VE
SEEN BROUGHT. AMONG SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT STUDENTS A SHOOTING
INVOLVING ELK GROVE UNIFIED
STUDENTS IN A FIGHT AT A HIGH
SCHOOL IN RICHMOND THAT LED TO
GUNFIRE. THE BILL SETS THE
FOUNDATION FOR DE ESCALATION
MODEL THAT WILL GIVE SCHOOLS THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO DEFUSE BROWN
SITUATIONS BEFORE THEY GET OUT
OF CONTROL. WE CAN TAKE PCS AS
THE POLICE CAMPUSES IS NOT WORK
INSTEAD WE NEED ADULTS TRAINED
IN THE TYPE OF THE ESCALATION
METHODS. THAT AVOID EXPOSING
CHILDREN TO THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE. AT A CONSISTENTLY SHOW
BUT STILL RFERRAL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SCHOOL RELATED
ARRESTS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. IN
FACT THE MOST RECENT DATA FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS. SHOWS
THAT WERE 25% OF SCHOOL ARRESTS
ARE OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. THE SUPERINTENDENT
LIKE TO BE FOR THIS BILL IS ONLY
A START. IN ORDER FOR DE
ESCALATION PROGRAMS TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN THE LONG RUN WE
WILL NEED TO GIVE SCHOOLS
OPTIONS TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF
FOR THIS PURPOSE NOT JUST TO
RETAIN AND RETRAIN EXISTING
EMPLOYEES. TEACHERS AND STAFF
ARE ALREADY OVERWHELMED HAVING
TAKEN ON ADDITIONAL ROLES DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND MOST ARE
STRETCHED TO THE LIMIT. FURTHER
NOT ALL EXISTING STAFF ARE WELL
SUITED TO LEARNING ENGAGING
THESE DE ESCALATE DE ESCALATION
METHODS. WE BELIEVE IN ORDER FOR
THESE TYPES OF THE ESCALATION
PROGRAMS TO MAKE A LASTING
IMPACT WE SHOULD BE TAKING
PRESSURE OFF OF EXISTING STAFF.
AND EMPOWERING SCHOOLS TO HIRE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE ALREADY
TURNED IN THE ESCALATION
METHODS. THIS IS NOT A NEW IDEA
WE SEE. ASSESSES RISK TO IT YES
STRATEGIES THIS IS A WAY TO X.
THIS. ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE. IT
IS MY SINCERE BELIEF THAT IF WE
CAN EXPAND THE ESCALATION
STRATEGIES IN OUR SCHOOLS. THAT
IT WILL IMPROVE SCHOOL CLIMATE
BY EMPOWERING STAFF TO DEFUSE
CONFLICTS AGAIN BEFORE IT ERUPTS
INTO VIOLENCE. WHILE ALSO
INTRODUCING STUDENTS TO WAYS
THEY CAN RESOLVE THEIR
DIFFERENCES WITHOUT TURNING TO
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SAYS FUND THIS BILL
TODAY. AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THIRTY OTHER PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
A. ANY OPPOSITION. MISTER GIBSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY BEYOND WHAT
PERSONAL ONE THANK HIM AS
WILLIAMS FOUR ONE STEPPING ON
BEHALF ARE SO PERTINENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION MR TONY THURMOND
THANK HIM FOR HIS- SPONSORSHIP
OF TWENTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR A
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR WILL
PROVIDE A SCHOOL A SCHOOL WITH
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO DE ESCALATE
STUDENT CONFLICT. AND DOES NOT
INVOLVE EXPOSING STUDENTS TO THE
SCHOOL PRISON PIPELINE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE BEST
PRACTICES MODELS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO HAVE DATA TO SUPPORT
IT LET'S LOOK AT THOSE KINDS OF-
OPPORTUNITIES TO INVEST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ONE WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE X. SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE YOUNG PEOPLE IS ONE
THIS PLEASANT ONE IS FOCUSED ON
LEARNING AND ALSO PUT THROUGH
THAT KIND OF ENVIRONMENT. I
RESPECT ASK AND I'VE ON. TWENTY
NINETY FOUR.
IT IS BEEN MOVING SECOND YES OR
NO. NOW IT WILL RUIN YOUR BAND
IT'S- SECOND MY WESTERN. ART MR
LEE SECOND AYE MR LATER NOT SEAT
UNDER APOLOGIZE I DID YOU
ALREADY CLOSED SO THAT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE IEM FOR AB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL NINTH
O'DONNELL I'D DALLY. DALLY
IDENTIT. SENATE I CHEN N. I. LI
LI I MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. IT IS SIX OH SO IT
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT WILL GO TO MISS RUBIO IS
MISS RUBIO IN THE ROOM I KNOW I
SEE MISTER SALAS ON HIS MAKE
ADJOURNMENTS REVEALS OUT HERE
SHE BETTER GET HER MISTER SALAS.
COME ON UP- SHE'S KANNST DOES
NOT DISREGARD THAT STATEMENT.
AND CHECK MY FACTS AS USUAL SO
WE'LL GO TO MISTER SALAS- AND
THEN WE'LL LOOK FOR MISTER V. OF
THE ABUJA AFTER THAT. YOUR MIKE
. YOUR LEFT. RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS PROUD TO PRESENT
AB NINETEEN FORTY WHICH WOULD BE
A BIG BILL FOR KIDS IN SCHOOL
FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS.
AB NINETEEN FORTY WILL UPDATE
MODERNIZE EXISTING SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS- THIS B. H. C.
GRANT PROGRAM TO MEET CURRENT
NEEDS OF STUDENT HEALTH I DO
HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND
LET'S OKAY WITH YOU MISTER
CHIRLA TO MOVE TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IT RECEIVED
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TEST TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY MY NAME IS SARA
LANCE I'M A SOCIAL WORK AND
TORRENT- INTERNET THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE AND
WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
OUR ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS AND
ADVOCATES FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY THREE ACTIVE SCHOOL
BUT HEALTH CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
THE TWENTY SEVEN EMERGING SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS AND MANY
SCHOOLS SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS INTERESTED IN
THIS MODEL HEALTH CARE. FOR MORE
THAN FIFTEEN YEARS GETTING FIRST
. AMALIA WAS GO BASED HEALTH
CENTERS AND THE HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACING STUDENTS. I
WOULD LIKE TO QUICKLY SHARE
THREE ASPECTS. THAT MAKE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS SO
EFFECTIVE PARTICULARLY FOR THIS
MOMENT. SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS DELIVER COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATED HEALTH CARE INCLUDING
BEHAVIOR HEALTH. SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS PROVIDE HER TEAM
BASED HEALTH CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS WORKING TOGETHER.
SOMETIMES EVEN DENTAL AND VISION
. BATES HEALTH CENTERS ARE
HELPING STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS
RECOVER FROM THE COBIT PANDEMIC
THERE PROVIDING COVER TESTING
AND VACCINATIONS AND HELPING
STUDENTS CATCH UP ON ON MATT AND
EXACERBATED HEALTH NEEDS DURING
THE PANDEMIC. SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS ARE A LOT AND
WITH COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THIS
PROGRAM FOCUSES ON SUPPORTING
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS AND
IS COMPATIBLE WITH THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS INVESTMENT. IT FOCUSES
ON FACILITY COSTS FOR NEW SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS AND
EXPANSION FOR EXISTING SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS. I PASSING
AB NINETEEN FORTY WE CAN MAKE
SURE THE GRANT PROGRAM ALREADY
IN STATUTE IS UP TO DATE AND
BETTER MEET THE CURRENT NEEDS OF
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS. YES REALLY QUICKLY
THANK YOU AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LISA EISENBERG AND
I'M THE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
PLAN. I WOULD LIKE TO. CLARIFY
SOME OF THE POINTS RAISED BY OUR
POINT OPPONENTS IN YESTERDAY'S
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE. FIRST
NO SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
THAT. PROVIDE MEDICATION
ASSISTED OR SURGICAL ABORTIONS.
SECOND THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES MENTIONED AND THE
STATUTE SECTION IS NOT CODE FOR
ABORTION- THE TYPES OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
THAT ARE PROVIDED IN SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS ARE AGE
APPROPRIATE. I'M SERVICES LIKE
TESTING AND TREATMENT FOR
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
DISPENSING AND PRESCRIBING
CONTRACEPTION AND PROVIDING INFO
ABOUT HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS. I'M
AND THEN FINALLY. NOT ALL SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS PROVIDE
THESE TYPES OF SERVICE. AND AB
NINETEEN FORTY DOESN'T EVEN
MANDATE THAT THEY DO. DELIVERING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICE.
THROUGH CLINICS AND SCHOOLS CAN
BE CONTENTIOUS WE RECOGNIZE THIS
WITH LOTS OF REGIONAL VARIATION.
I'M THAT'S WHY LOCAL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL LEADERS
HAVE OF. WEALTH OVER. HIS HEAD
AND- HEALTH. IN FACT ONE OF
THEM. MY SCHOOL BE CENTER SO.
MANY DIFFERENT IS THAT THEY WERE
THE LOCAL NEED OF THAT AND A DAY
THEIR SERVE AS NEEDED THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I ARE DRIVE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING WHAT
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS DO
AND DON'T DO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OTHERS IN PART. CHAIR MEMBERS
HAS SUBPOENAED I MEET IS NOT
FINNA BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HAS ANY
OPPOSITION YOU MAY COME FORWARD.
SEEN OPPOSITION BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISH TO
COMMENT WE HAVE A MOTION. THIS
MCCARTY MOVES- MISTER O'DONNELL
SECONDS. ARE YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU MISTER. FILE ITEM SIX AB
NINETEEN FORTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
I DON'T KNOW I'D DALLY DALLY NO
SENATE. VENETI CHEN. FAN NOT
VOTING LEAVE. MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE QUIRK-SILVA. THE BILL HAS
THREE VOTES IT IS SO IT IS ON
CALL. ALL. WITH THAT IS THIS
YOUR BE A PUT IN THE ROOM. YES
THE NEW. OKAY IS HE COMING TO IN
OUR. WITH YOUR AVAILABLE IF WE
DO HURDLE TO OVERCOME. THIS TO.
THAT. IT'S ODD THIS WEBER COME
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA WILL WILL
NOT TAKE ALL THREE OF YOUR BILLS
. YOU YOU YOU GOT HERE BEFORE
OTHERS THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS RIGHT
NOW. AND YOU'RE GONNA START WITH
. FILE NUMBER TEN IT'S AB. TWO
FIVE NINE EIGHT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS. I WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR ALL
OF ITS WORK AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWO FIVE NINE EIGHT. WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
CREATE AN ADVISORY BOARD TO
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICE MODELS OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE TO MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE ON THE CDC WEBSITE.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES
AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
EMPATHISE REPAIRING THE HARM
DONE TO PEOPLE AND RELATIONSHIPS
RATHER THAN SOLELY FOCUSING ON
PUNISHING THE OFFENDERS.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE HAS ITS
ROOTS IN ANCIENT AND INDIGENOUS
PRACTICES EMPLOYED IN CULTURES
ALL OVER THE WORLD. A STUDY DONE
BY DOCTOR JANET ROSENBAUM FROM
DOWNSTATE SCIENCE UNIVERSITY.
ALLEN THAT ALTHOUGH REMOVING THE
STUDENT FROM THE CLASSROOM HELP
THE IMMEDIATE CLASS CLIMATE THE
STUDENT WHO WAS PUNISHED WAS
MORE LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN
ANTISOCIAL BEHAVIOUR. HAVE
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM USE MARIJUANA
TOBACCO AND BE ARRESTED DURING
THE SUSPENSION AND WITHIN THE
YEAR OF SUSPENSION. LONGITUDINAL
RESEARCH SHOW THAT SUSPENDED
STUDENTS WERE LESS LIKELY TO
EARN THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE
AND PURSUE A DEGREE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. YOUTH AND
PARTICULARLY MINORITY YOUTH WHEN
EXPOSED TO THE TRADITIONAL
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM I'M MORE
LIKELY TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
ADULT CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BLACK MEN IN CALIFORNIA ARE FIVE
POINT FIVE TIMES OVER
REPRESENTED COMPARED TO THAT
POPULATION AND LATINOS ARE TWO
POINT NINE TIMES OVER
REPRESENTED. IT IS CLEAR THAT
CURRENT METHODS OF PROPERLY
ADDRESSING YOUTH OFFENSES HAVE
NOT PRODUCE THE RESULTS INTENDED
AND HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED YOUTH OF COLOR. PLACING
THEM ON THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE. AS A MOM OF TWO BOYS
IT IS HEARTENING TO SEE THAT
BOYS WHO ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT 51%
OF ENROLLMENT RECEIVE ALMOST 70%
OF IN SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS. AND
70% OF OUT OF SCHOOL
SUSPENSIONS. ADDITIONALLY IT IS
TROUBLING THAT ABOUT 31% OF
BLACK STUDENTS RECEIVED ONE OR
MORE IN SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS AND
38% RECEIVED ONE OR MORE OUT OF
SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
. AND AS A MOM OF TWO BLACK BOYS-I AM FORTUNATELY HAVE MY OWN
PERSONAL STORY. THAT BY MY BOYS
HAVING TO VERY EDUCATED PARENTS
AND A GRANDMOTHER WHO IS FAIRLY
WELL KNOWN. THEY HAVE ALSO
RECEIVED HARSHER DISCIPLINE IN
SCHOOL WHEN COMPARED TO THEIR
COUNTERPARTS FOR THE SAME ACTION
. THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
CULTURES AND ETHNICITIES BUT
ALSO STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO RECEIVE MORE IN SCHOOL AND
OUT OF SCHOOL SUSPENSIONS.
THIRTY FIVE FOUND RETORT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES TO
BE BENEFICIAL NOT ONLY IMPROVE
STUDENT BEHAVIOR SUCH AS
DECREASES AND FIGHTING AND
PULLING. BUT ALSO WOULD DECREASE
AN OFFICE REFERRALS CLASSROOM
REMOVALS SUSPENSIONS AND
EXPULSIONS. THAT IS ALSO SUGGEST
A LINK BETWEEN RESTORATIVE
APPROACHES AND IMPROVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE OUTCOMES INCLUDING
INCREASED LEVELS OF STUDENT
CONNECTEDNESS. PROVE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN TEN
TEACHERS AND IMPROVED
MISPERCEPTIONS OF SCHOOL CLIMATE
. AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WOULD GIVE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO BEGIN THE
USE OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BEST
PRACTICE AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
SUSPENSION EXPULSION OR ARREST.
IT REQUIRE THE CDP TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A
STANDARD MODEL TO IMPLEMENT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BEST
PRACTICES ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS AND
MAKE THE STANDARD MODEL
AVAILABLE ON THE CD'S INTERNET
WEBSITE FOR USE BY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IMPLEMENT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PRACTICES AS A PART. OF
THE EFFORT TO IMPROVE CAMPUS
CULTURE AND CLIMATE. THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. AND TALKING
PEACE AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND OTHERS. HERE TO
SPEAK WITH ME TODAY THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS DR PAUL COUGH COLD. AND
DOCTOR WATSON A SCHOLAR ACTIVIST
FACULTY DIRECTOR AND PROFESSOR
OF EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP AND
RACIAL JUSTICE AND THE COLLEGE
OF EDUCATION AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TEAR TWO
WITNESSES- TWO MINUTES EACH
POLICE YOU MAY PROCEED. IN THE
SUN WE'RE GOOD ALL RIGHT MY NAME
IS DR VISOR WATSON I'M THE
FACULTY DIRECTOR. AND AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN
EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP AT SAC
STATE I'M A FORMER HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER RECEIVED MY DOCTORATE
ADMINISTRATION PLANNING AND
SOCIAL POLICY FROM HARVARD
UNIVERSITY. OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS MY RESEARCH IS FOCUSED. ON
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTIONS TO THE
PUNISHMENT CRISIS IN SCHOOLS AS
SCHOLARS WHO STUDY DISCIPLINE
POLICY YOU KNOW. THAT WE CAN
SUSPEND OUR WAY TO SAFER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPING A HEALTHY CLIMATE AND
CULTURE CANNOT BE FORCED HOWEVER
IT CAN BE CULTIVATED. HERE'S
WHAT WE KNOW WE'RE SORT OF THE
CENTER'S DIALOGUE AND MEDIATION
- TO ESTES ACKNOWLEDGES HARM BUT
IS PRIMARILY ON COMPASSION AND
HEALING. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS
COLLECTIVE AND INVOLVES MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IS RELATIONAL RESPECTFUL AND
RESPONSIBLE. NOW WHAT KIND OF
SCHOOL DID YOU ATTEND AND WHICH
KIND OF SCHOOLS YOU WANT YOUR
CHILDREN OR GRANDCHILDREN TO
GROW UP INSIDE. A SCHOOL THAT'S
FILLED WITH RIGOR AND JOY OR
RIDICULE AN INJURY OVER THE LAST
TWO DECADES CALIFORNIA HAS
CHOSEN THE LATTER HOW DID WE GET
HERE. IN THE NINETEEN NINETY TWO
THOUSAND THE POLICE PRESENCE ON
PUBLIC SCHOOL CAMPUSES INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY. UNDER ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICIES SINCE THEN
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS. HAVE
BECOME THE MOST RAPIDLY GROWING
SEGMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE
INTENTION OF THESE POLICIES WAS
TO MAKE SCHOOLS SAFER FOR OUR
CHILDREN THE DATA SHOWS THAT
GOAL WAS NOT EVEN ACCOMPLISHED.
REMOVING POLICE IS JUST ONE STEP
BUT THE REALLOCATION OF THE
FUNDS ONCE USED TO PAY FOR THEM
UP. INTO RESTORED OF RESOURCES
IS CRITICAL AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT IS ESSENTIAL
LEGISLATION OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
TAKING IMPORTANT STEPS TO DEFINE
THE POLICE. WITHIN THE LA- AND-
THOSE RESOURCES NEED TO BE RE
ALLOCATED TO RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT MELTED DOWN THEIR GUNS
AND DECOMMISSION THEIR PATROL
VEHICLES THEY USE THE SAME FUNDS
THEY WERE ONCE USED FOR THE OVER
POLICING OF CHILDREN OF COLOR
AND CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
TO TRAIN AND HIRE RESTORATIVE
CULTURE AND CLASS. WE MAKES
SCHOOLS THIS IS HOW WE DEVELOP
HEALTHIER LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
PLEASE SOME RISE. UP CLOSE WITH
THIS IN EAST AFRICA TRADITIONAL
READING PASSED AMONG THE MASAI
WARRIORS IS HOW IS THE CHILDREN.
THESE LEGENDARY FIGHTERS IN
KENYA WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
CHILDREN OF THEIR OWN GIVE THE
SAME CALMING ANSWER. ALL THE
CHILDREN ARE WELL THIS SIMPLE
STATEMENT PROVIDES INSIGHT INTO
A CULTURAL TRADITION. THE
PRIORITIZE A KID NEEDS OF THE
YOUNG I HOPE CALIFORNIA DOES THE
SAME THANK YOU THANK YOUR NEXT
WITNESS TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU JERRY DONNELLAN WILL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SURE
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT FOR YOUR ON GOING SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC ADD. YOUR LEADERSHIP
DURING THESE EXTRAORDINARY TIMES
THE FORMER COURT SCHOOL TEACHER
FOR THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THE EARLY
NINETIES I HAD THE HONOR OF
WORKING WITH SPELLED
INCARCERATED YOUTH. EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD ASSIST
SCHOOL OFFICIALS TO RETHINK HOW
WHICH THEIR CHILDREN
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN NEED PRIOR
TO THE LOCKDOWN. ONLY 53% OF
ELEVENTH GRADERS REPORTED THEY
HAD A CONNECTION TO SCHOOL IN
ONLY SIXTY TWO PERCEPTIVE A LONG
ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT. PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK
FOR SCHOOL. NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. THAT LEAD TO THOSE
BEHAVIORS THE DEPARTURE FROM
MANY TRADITIONAL PRACTICES THAT
POSH THE SYMPTOM WITHOUT REGARD
TO THE Y. IN OUR EXPERIENCE VAST
MAJORITY DISCIPLINARY ISSUES I'M
MORE A CRY FOR HELP FROM THE
STUDENT RATHER THAN A REFLECTION
OF THE CHILD REALLY IS. STARTED
PRACTICES CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAMILY
STUDENTS SCHOOL OFFICIALS TO
WORK TOGETHER IN A MUCH
DIFFERENT CAUGHT THE PROMOTES
DIALOGUE IN DEEPENING
RELATIONSHIPS. OUR EXPERIENCE IS
WHEN A STUDENT FEELS EMPOWERED
AND IN CONTROL OF HIS OR HER OWN
AGENCY ILLNESS AND EVIDENTLY
CHANGED NEGATIVE BEHAVIORS. AS A
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT FULLY
COMMITTED TO STRENGTHENING
RELATIONSHIPS TO RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE CENTER STAFFED WITH
CERTIFICATED TEACHER. TO MENTAL
HEALTH THERE. STUDENT NEEDED TO
BE REMOVED FROM A CLASS I CAN.
THEY WERE. TO THE SENATE WITH.
THE MENTAL HEALTH INTAKE IN
ORDER TO FIND OUT IF THERE WERE
OTHER ISSUES. TO BE AWARE OF TO
PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT TO THE
STUDENT FAMILY. IN ADDITION.
ACADEMIC WORK FROM THE CLASS
CAME WITH THEM AND THEY RECEIVED
SUPPORT FROM THE TEACHER RICHARD
AND THEY WOULD NOT FALL BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY. FINALLY NATIONAL
EFFORTS BROUGHT EDUCATORS AND
FAMILIES TOGETHER TO COME UP
WITH. HOW THEY WOULD MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER FROM THAT POINT
ON. NONE OF THIS WAS DICTATED TO
ANYONE THE AGREEMENTS WERE
UNANIMOUS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
STUDENTS WERE NOT SAID HOME IN
THE COURSE OF THE SEVEN YEARS.
OUR DISTRICT WENT FROM A 58%
GRADUATION RATE TO OVER 93% WELL
SUSPENSIONS DECREASED 18% TO
UNDER TWO PERCENT. AT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WE'VE BILL TO RESTORE PRACTICES
TEAM OF THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
PARTNERED WITH THE NATIONAL
CONFLICT RESOLUTION CENTER TO
SUPPORTER DISTRICTS AND OF
TRAINED OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
SCHOOL OFFICIALS. BOTH
CERTIFICATED AND CLASSIFIED IN
THIS APPROACH. IN ONE DISTRICT
WE EXPERIENCE A SEVENTY THREE
SUNRISE. FIVE IN DATA FROM OUR
DISTRICTS WERE SEEN INCREDIBLE
RESULTS 82% REDUCTION SUSPENSION
PARTICULAR FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. WE STAND BY WILLIAM
READY READY AND WILLING TO
ASSIST IN EVERY WAY WE CAN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WELL DONE. WITH
THAT OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MAY COME FORWARD. WHAT DID
YOU JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SO
WHITE CM. WE ARE THE- CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
REPRESENTING DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF TALKING PEACE
WHO IS ANOTHER SPONSOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
REASONABLE AVAILABLE
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER IN SUPPORT. JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION SUPPORT.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
INDICATOR WATCH A WITH THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. HI GUYS ARE GONNA BE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU- ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SEE NO OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTARY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR MCCARTY. I JUST- OR
MOVE THE BILL AND I THINK I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A COST SEVENTY
PLEASE ADD ME I TRIED THIS EXACT
SAME BILL. FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
WE WERE HELD ON SUSPENSE AMONG
THE ONE OF THE HOUSES OF-
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE A BETTER
OUTCOME THIS YEAR THANK YOU. ARE
YOU ON AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU
A SECOND THE BILL. SO IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY MR MCCARTY SECOND
MISTER BENNETT SEEING NO FURTHER
COMMITTEE GIVE YOU ALSO MIGHT
MAKE TWO QUICK CONTACT I THINK
THERE'S TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL FOR
THIS. TO IMPROVE. GO DISTRICTS-
HANDLE THESE YOUNG PEOPLE SO I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
HOW THIS. IS THE BEGINNING STEPS
OF THIS WORK OUT. THANK YOU
BILL. THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
COMMITTEE COMMENT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU. SO IT IS LONG OVERDUE
FOR CALIFORNIA TO IMPLEMENT
ALTERNATIVES TO EXCLUSIONARY
PUNISHMENTS. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IS A HOLISTIC ALTERNATIVE THAT
WILL HELP KEEP OUR CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL. AND GIVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY. THANK YOU
AWARE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
THE TWENTY NINETY EIGHT THE MOST
AS YOU PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I DON'T
KNOW I DALLI DALLI IDENTIT
SENATE I CHEN THEN I LEAVE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA
. THE BILL HAS FIVE ALSO IS OUT
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO. WHICH WHAT DO YOU KNOW
WHICH ONE YOU PREFER TO DO IF
YOU DON'T MIND I WOULD LIKE TO
DO AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
SO THE KIDS CAN GET BACK TO
SCHOOL TWENTY SEVEN SIR HORACE
WHERE THEY BELONG- YES SO WE'LL
GO FILE ITEM ELEVEN FILE ITEM
ELEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. MILLISECOND GET MY.
OKAY A TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
I FILE I'M ELEVEN YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN SHERIN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR I'LL
SEE IF AFTER. PERFORMING
SUBGROUP. CALIFORNIA IS A STATE
THAT VALUES EDUCATION. WE HAVE
SOME OF THE BEST SCHOOLS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN THE
WORLD. AND YET WE HAVE A SUB
GROUP OF OUR CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
CHRONICALLY LEFT BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS FROM THIS COMMITTEE
THIS ACADEMIC GAP HAS BEEN
PRESENT FOR DECADES. THE MOST
RECENT DATA BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SHOWS
THAT IN 201967% OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS DON'T READ OR
WRITE AT GRADE LEVEL AND MORE
THAN SEVENTY NINE PERCENT. ARE
BELOW GRADE LEVEL IN MATH. JUST
LET THOSE NUMBERS SINK IN. THIS
MEANS THAT ONLY 33% OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE PROFICIENT IN READING AND
ONLY 21% OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
PERCENT PROFICIENT IN MATH. THAT
MEANS WE ARE KILLING THESE
CHILDREN. 33% AND 21% ON ANY
EXAM IS AN AFT. THIS IS AN ODD
THING THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN
ESPECIALLY IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS SO MANY
RESOURCES. WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF A STRONG ACADEMIC
FOUNDATION AND THAT EDUCATION IS
THE GREAT EQUALIZER. THE
FOUNDATION THAT WE ARE CREATING
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS IS
BROKEN AND AN EQUAL. WE SHOULD
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES TO THOSE
THAT NEED IT THE MOST. AND THAT
WAS THE REASON BEHIND CREATING
L. C. F. F. TO PROVIDE FOR
EQUITABLE FUNDING AMONG LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO ADDRESS
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. AND YET IN
MANY OF OUR LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP ARE AN ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM L. C. F. F. BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT BELONG TO ONE OF THE CURRENT
SUB GROUPS THAT RECEIVED EXTRA
FUNDING. AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WILL CORRECT THIS BY
CREATING A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT. FOR THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP AND THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. JOINING US HERE
TODAY WE HAVE THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL DR MARGARET FORTUNE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF REX AND
MARJORIE FOURTEEN SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION I'M BROOKLYN WILLIAMS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF EDUCATION. YOU
MAY PERCEIVE IN REDDING. AB YOU
KNOW YOUR MICROPHONE IS HONESTLY
THAT MIKE BUT RIGHT THANK YOU DR
WEBER MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DR MARGARET FORTUNE I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF FOURTEEN SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION THE SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. CO
SPONSORS ARE ONLY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND DOUBLE ACP STATE CONFERENCE
AND DOUBLE ACP SAMBAR TO DINO
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK WESTERN
REGION AND SACRAMENTO CHAPTER.
INTERNATIONAL FAITH BASED
COALITION ALSO COMMUNITY
EDUCATION INITIATIVE NATIONAL
COALITION OF A HUNDRED BLACK
WOMEN SET OF AND STATE SUPER
REPUBLICAN STRUCTURE IN TONY
THURMOND I'M HERE TODAY TO THE
FLAW IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA IN AN EFFORT TO
TARGET RESOURCES TO THE HIGHEST
NEEDS STUDENTS IN THE STATE. AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
CREATES A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
FOR THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP OF STUDENTS NOT
CURRENTLY RECEIVING SUPPLEMENTAL
STATE OR FEDERAL FUNDING. BLACK
STUDENTS BLACK STUDENTS
IRRESPECTIVE OF INCOME ARE
PERFORMING BELOW THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE IN BOTH ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS AND MATH 67% OF BLACK
STUDENTS NOT READ OR WRITE A
GREAT DEAL AND 79% DO NOT MEET
MATH STANDARDS. A UC BERKELEY
STUDY FOUND THAT SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS RECEIVING
CONCENTRATION GRANTS DURING THE
INITIAL TWO YEARS OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA DIDN'T
ENGAGE IN ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
THAT PARALLELS GATE IN PUPIL
ACHIEVEMENT. BUT THEY ALSO NOTED
THAT THEIR INABILITY TO DETECT
GAINS FOR BLACK STUDENTS IS
WORRISOME THESE EARLY FINDINGS
SUGGEST THAT WHILE L. CFS
SUPPLEMENTS AB IMPROVE OUTCOME.
OUTCOMES FOR SOME STUDENTS A
NOTABLE GAP REMAINS FOR BLACK
STUDENTS EIGHTY THOUSAND BLACK
STUDENTS ARE NOT RECEIVING
ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
OR ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS.
UNFUNDED BLACK STUDENTS ARE THE
ONLY SUBGROUP PERFORMING BELOW
THE STATE WIDE AVERAGE ON E. LA
IN MATH THAT IS NOT ALREADY
RISK. L. C. F. F. SUPPLEMENT. A
TWENTY SEVEN SEP FOUR WOULD
GENERATE AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
UNFUNDED BLACK STUDENTS ALONG
WITH L. CAP ACCOUNTABILITY. WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR AND THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THEIR CHANCE
TO TESTIFY THANK YOU. TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M BROOKLYN WILLIAMS SENIOR
ADVISER THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. AND I'M
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN. WHO IS
THE CO SPONSOR OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THE
SUPERINTENDENT WAS THE CO AUTHOR
OF THE PREVIOUS VERSION OF THIS
BILL AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE.
BY HER MOTHER SECRETARY OF STATE
DR SHIRLEY WEBER AND WE ARE
THRILLED TO SEE THE BATON
PASSED. THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION PLACE IS
EQUITY AND OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
STUDENTS AT THE CENTER OF HIS
AGENDA. CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE
STRUGGLING TO COPE WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS DEATHS. MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
THE EFFECTS OF SOCIAL AND RACIAL
INJUSTICE. AS WELL AS POVERTY
AND SO MUCH MORE. UNFORTUNATELY
THESE TRAUMAS FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
OF COLOR. WE MUST TAKE BOLD
ACTION NOW TO MEET STUDENTS
NEEDS AND TO REDUCE THE LEARNING
LOSS THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED. THE
MORE DATA FOR YOU TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN STATEWIDE TESTING DATA
SHOW THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS ARE THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUBGROUP WITH ONLY
49% MEETING E. L. A. STANDARDS
AND ONLY 33% MEETING MATH
STANDARDS. THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
FOR ALL STUDENTS WITH 51%
MEETING L. E. LA AND- 1% MATH.
DESPITE THIS EVER GOING TO MAKE
GAP AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
ARE NOT DESIGNATED AS HIGH NEEDS
UNDER L. CFS. ONE KEY WAY WE CAN
HELP TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP IS BY CREATING A NEW
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT. IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA FOR THE
LOWEST PERFORMING SUBGROUP OF
STUDENTS NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING%
FUNDS. FOR CONTEXT IN THE FALL
THE SUPERINTENDENT ANNOUNCED
PLANS TO BUILD A STRATEGY TO
IMPROVE AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO ADVANCE THIS GOAL HE
CONVENED A TASK FORCE THAT
BROUGHT TOGETHER PRACTITIONERS
ADVOCATES RESEARCHERS FOUNDATION
PARTNERS THOUGHT LEADERS. OTHER
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD TO IDENTIFY
KEY STRATEGIES TO INFORM POLICY
AND PRACTICE. AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR ALIGNS WITH THAT CHARGE AND
IS A CRITICAL AND TIMELY
INVESTMENT. IF THE COVER NOTHING
PANDEMIC HAS WORSENED
EDUCATIONAL INEQUITIES THANK YOU
. WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE EDUARDO PRE TIME
JUMP THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
MAY COME FORWARD ME STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY PLEASE. IT IS NOT
A TIME FOR TESTIMONY FURTHER
THAN THAT. WHEN YOU COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. IS LINED UP
THERE MAYBE DISTANCE A LITTLE
BIT. AND WE MAY START THANK YOU
HELLO I AM SHALL CLASS CELL OF
SAMPOERNA DINO CALIFORNIA
CONCERNED MOTHER. AND A MEMBER
OF THE N. DOUBLE ACP SAMPOERNA
DINO IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHLOE FERGUSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BLACK CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TO WHITE SEEM ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS TACK ALLEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE INTERNATIONAL FAITH BASED
COALITION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR RAMONA
BISHOP I AM A FORMER
SUPERINTENDENT OF FORMER. ALL
THINGS PUBLIC SCHOOL. NOW
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF MY OWN
CHARTER SCHOOL NETWORK DEDICATED
TO ELIMINATING THE OPPORTUNITY
GAP FOR BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS. ON HALF. BOARD OF
ELITE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT BEHIND IT THANK YOU
AT. ALL THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOHN TAYLOR I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR.
I AM THE- PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
SACRAMENTO ALUMNI CHAPTER OF
ALPHA PHI THIRTY INCORPORATED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO MY
NAME IS ROXANNE IS ARIELLE I AM
A PARENTS AND I'M ALSO-
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ASSEMBLY
DELEGATE REPRESENTING EIGHTY
THIRTY NINE AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DARLENE V.
TRIAL I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK ORANGE
COUNTY CHAPTER. AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR NO JUSTICE NO PEACE. HELLO
DOCTOR TO COURT PORTER ON THE
PHONE THE PRESIDENT THE NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS
SANDRA SWANSON I'M A PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE
CHAIR OF THE ALPHA COMMUNITY
EDUCATION INITIATIVE AND I'M
HERE TO STATE THAT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICH SMITH
I HEAR I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
WESTERN REGION OF ALPHA PHI
ALPHA FRATERNITY INCORPORATED.
THE PACIFIC REGION OF SIGMA PI
PHI FRATERNITY INCORPORATED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RYAN
MCCURRY I AM THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISH DIRECTOR AND I
REPRESENT ALL CHAPTERS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALFALFA ATTORNEY
INCORPORATED. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON FRANCINE MAXWELL
CHAIRWOMAN OF BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN UNITED OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE I
MISS ROSA BLACKMON I'M DELAY CAN
COMMUNICATE ALSO CHAIR HERE IN
SAN DIEGO. WE ARE VERY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE REVEREND
JONATHAN MOSELEY. WESTERN REGION
DIRECTOR NATIONAL ACTION
NETWORK. WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAURIE
CAN DENNIS PRESIDENT OF NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK ANGELES AND WE
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTING MY NAME IS
ROBERT BROTHERS A MEMBER ALPHA
PHI ALPHA FRATERNITY
INCORPORATED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER WE'RE STRONG SUPPORTERS
FROM THE BILL TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. GET AFTERNOON COMMITTING.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR EARLY IN A
WALLER. FOUNDER OF WILLIE J.
FRANK COLLEGE PREP IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M CRISTINA LASTER THE-
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK REACH
WESTERN REGIONAL EDUCATION
ADVISER AND LIAISON I AM ALSO
THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY. NATION
WITH THE NATIONAL PARA. AND I
SUPPORT THE PARENT I SUPPORT ME
AS A PARENT AND A GRANDPARENT
AND I AM STRONGLY IN THANK YOU
ART AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
YOU'RE WELCOME. MY NAME IS ELLEN
NASH AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY NINE I
AM ALSO I SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF
THE SAN DIEGO CHAPTER. CAN
POLITICAL SHARE THE LEON
WILLIAMS SAN DIEGO COUNTY HUMAN
RELATIONS COMMISSION AND WE
DEFINITELY SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU. LIBERA IS
ON BEHALF OF THE DIVERSITY IN
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
. MY GUYS ARE GONNA BE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. I'M
TRACY STAFFORD THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BLACK CAUCUS AND A MOTHER FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS OF MINORS AND
WE IF WE DEFINITELY I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL A- USE. MY
NAME IS MEL THERE A WOODS I AM A
MEMBER OF ALPHA PHI ALPHA
FRATERNITY INCORPORATED THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AND I SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
WILLIAM CAREY I WITH THE ALFALFA
TURNING COOPERATED AND WE ARE AS
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. GREETINGS MY NAME IS DEMOS
JOHNSON THE THIRD I AM A MEMBER
OF ALPHA PHI ALPHA FRATERNITY
INCORPORATED THE GAMMA PHI
LAMBDA CHAPTER AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEP
FOURTH THANK. HELLO MY NAME'S
KEELING HUNTER I'M A MEMBER OF
PHI A FRATERNITY COOPERATE
DEMOCRATIC ATLANTA CHAPLAINCY
DIDN'T HE WERE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M EDUCATOR AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. THE
NEW MY NAME IS DOCTOR MILLER
MCELWEE I'M A MEMBER OF AL I
OFFERED IN INCORPORATED AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CARLA
PORTER AND ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK WE DON'T SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY. BEFORE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IN MEMBERS
ANGELINA TEARS ON BEHALF OF LA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRIAN RIVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT. RACHEL GATES EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. ANTHONY
JOHNSON EDUCATOR IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO
UNDISCOUNTED TODAY AND I'M A
LEAD REPRESENTATIVE OF TWO AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COREY
MESHACH I'M IN HIGH SCHOOL
ENGLISH TEACHER AND REPRESENTING
ELITE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SETS OF. MY NAME IS
GIULIANA RODRIGUEZ IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS AND I. HI AND OLD V. TWO
SEVEN SANTA LACK. I AM MONEY AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHT B. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME
IS FAITH LOPEZ AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS ALLEY IN
FOUR. MY NAME IS SHALL SEE
HIDING IN IN SUPPORT OF AB B.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FORGET JANICE
FOURTEEN. ITALY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
CARMEN IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
MILES IN SUPPORT OF. A. B. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO I'M A
PARENT OF MONEY SMITH MY NAME IS
TATIANA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS LORI L. SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN FOR. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER THE PART OF
A. B. YEAH A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS ROSHAN
AND I SUPPORT. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS CANDY AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR IN GREAT COMPANIES-
FOURTEEN. HI MY NAME IS GIOVANNI
TODD IS. IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR GOOD JOB NEEDS
. HI AM NATALIE ALVAREZ AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS GERRY NORMAN IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU BASS FORTUNE
FORTUNE. MY NAME IS AHMED IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS SAMUEL IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS SOPHIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS KEIKO IN
SUPPORT AND T. THESE. A. B. T.
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ARE
YOU NEW TO IN SUPPORT OF AB T.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS ARGHA. IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS JAMES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU
AS MUCH AS- I AREAS MATTER SINCE
. SUPPORT OF. FROM FROM FROM A.
B. SEVEN ZERO FOUR. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS SHANE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
AND YOU ARE. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHANE SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS KEVIN
AND SUPPORT OF AB TWO SERVICING
FOR. HI MY NAME IS ASIA PER
MEDIA SUPPORTER OF AB. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS SPRINGER IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS JASON DNA AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS BOND JANET I
AM IN. MY NAME BONTA ENDS IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO TWO SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS AMANDA HERNANDEZ IN SUPPORT
OF TWO AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS GOOD REAR END UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS IN NAIRA IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT B. TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. MY NAME IS KING UP AND IS
A PART OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS A PROFIT AS A POOR OF
A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS CASING CARTER IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS MASS ZERO TAYLOR AND MY
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS KAI
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS A VERY IN
SUPPORT OF AB B. TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. MY NAME IS TO IT JACKSON
THIS IS PART OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS CLEAR
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS SAVANNAH IN
SUPPORT OF AB T. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS A MINUTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS MY NAME
IS AND IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWO
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A LITTLE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS JAY AND I'M
IN SUPPORT AB. TWO SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS CONNIE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS THE
VAN I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. FOLLOWED BY
LIVES TO LEARN A LITTLE
SURPRISED AB TWO SERVICE OF FOR
. MY NAME IS A GUY IN SUPPORT OF
THE TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS JAIL AND A FOR A TWO AND
A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS JUST SIGN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
CHELSEA AND THE POOR AND A. B.
C. TO CENTER FOR. MY NAME IS
DIEGO I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
RICARDO IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SINCERE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
COREY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS MELANIE
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ERIC AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
MY NAME IS RYAN I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS ON THE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SOME FOUR. MY NAME IS
MAKAYLA. MY NAME IS MAKAYLA IN
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS DOMINIQUE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO AB. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS DANIEL
AND I SUPPORT AB. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MONYMUSK ASTROLOGY
NOT. MONYMUSK ASANTE BURN IN
SUPPORT OF AB. MY NAME IS THE L.
WALKER IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ASHTON IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
CHARLIZE AND I IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
JOHN LIMA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS THE
MON IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS JAY
HUNTER IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
EVANGELION IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ANNE ST IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
NINA INTO FOUR OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS LAURA AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS BOTH GONNA TAKE
ADVANTAGE I MEAN MY NAME IS
GONNA TAKE AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS BELLA
AND SUPPORTED- AB TWO SOON FOR.
MY NAME IS MCCARTY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS ADAM IN I'M IN
IN SO FAR AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS JOSHUA AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MAY KILL SHRINK
FOUR. MY NAME IS OSCAR JIMENEZ
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS JUVENILE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS LANA SEARS AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR MY NAME IS A LEAD
GENERATION IN SUPPORT OF TWO
SEVEN SEVENFOUR. MY NAME IS A
MONEY IN SUPPORT OF. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
CHEVALLEY- IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOSEPH TURNER I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR THANK
. HELLO MY NAME IS A NOD. AND I
AM SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS OLIVIA AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN
ZERO FOUR. MY NAME IS ADAM I AM
IN SUPPORT OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS JASON RAIMES
SUPPORT OF. AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HELLO I'M JIM ARE GOOD WHEN I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS A MAN AND
I'M A SUPPORT OF AB TO CENSOR.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM MOIR AND I
SUPPORT. AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. HI MY NAME IS CHERYL AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS JOE SIGH AND
I SUPPORT. OF AB FOR HI MY NAME
IS TO LAND I SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
CENTS AND FOR. MY NAME IS DR
CARLY GALBRAITH AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS NATION I
SUPPORT. EIGHTY TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS KELLY AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS CAITLYN IT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS CHRISTINE AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME'S RENEE AND I SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS KILEY ALASKA FOR A B.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ARGHA SEN I SUPPORT A. B. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ASKS AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS YOU JANET
AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS BILLY MAN
NINETY SUPPORT B. AB TWO SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS JORDAN AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS JELENA AND
I SUPPORT. A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
. MY NAME IS VICTOR HARMON AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS A CURRENT AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN TWO
FOUR. MY NAME IS ARIANNA SUPPORT
A. B. TO SOMEONE'S HOME FOR. MY
NAME IS TRAILER ON AN ICE FOR AB
TO SUFFER FOR. MY NAME IS KAREN
NOT POOR AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MIKE A AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS TESTING US FOR AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS SHARON AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
MY NAME IS PEYTON ROYCE FOR
CLASS TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS NATALIE AND I SUPPORT A.
B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS NINE I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SO FAR. MY NAME IS CHRIS AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. HI MY NAME IS TAYLOR AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SENSE OF FOR. HI
MY NAME IS ANNE LAST SUPPORT A.
B. TWO SEVEN FOUR FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS CHIANTI NIGHTS AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. HI MY NAME IS COST FOUR TWO
SEVEN ZERO FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
MISS MONICA BLOCKS AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS DOES NOT SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
LEAH I AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
HI MY NAME IS A MAN I SWEAR AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. ONE AS
OURS SO OUR LEARNERS LAWYERS ARE
SOME WERE. A. B. TO SERVE SIMPLE
. HI MY NAME IS CARRY ON AND I
SUPPORT AV NO AB TWO SEVEN SOME
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS ALEX AND I
SUPPORT AB. TWO SEVEN TO TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S
RUSHING IN I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME
IS NICHOLAS AND I SUPPORT TO BE
I MEAN AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS DANIEL I SUPPORT AB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
LEAH CHAU CRABS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. MULLIN IMAGES STEINORTH
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS VICTORIA. AB TWO
THOUSAND. MY NAME IS LONDON AND
I SUPPORT AB T. SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME'S AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN ZERO FOUR. MY NAME IS THE
POINT I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS MORE THAN
A SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS DAN AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
MY NAME TOMORROW AS I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS LI
WON AN OSCAR FOR EIGHT. MY AND I
AND I SUPPORT A V. TWO SEVEN
ZERO FOUR. MY NAME IS LIZ AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS JOE AND I SUPPORT A
B. B. TWO SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS LEO AND I SUPPOSE. MY
NAME IS LEO. AND I SUPPORT AB.
TWO TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS TAYLOR AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S
CAROLINA SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS KIANA AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
MY NAME IS A LAN AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME
IS AND I SUPPORT REACHED THERE
WAS A- MY NAME IS. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS BROOKLYN
I SUPPORT A BEACHES OF ST FOR.
MY NAME IS CLEAR AND I SUPPORT
IT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS LISA MASSPORT A. B. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS THE
MILEAGE IN ASKING FOR AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A
MY WILL OPEN AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
BEN AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS EMMA AS A
FOUR EIGHTY TWO CENTS AND FOR.
MY NAME IS EVEN I'M SUPPORT A.
B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS JASMINE SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS LIFE AND
OUR SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SO
FORTH MY NAME'S TABI NASA FOR IT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME
IS JAZZ PRE AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
KENNY IN. RIGHT IN A SUBWAY A-
TWO SEVEN OVER. MY NAME IS
MELISSA AND I SUPPORT AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS MY
LEE AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS YOUR RISE
AND I SUPPORT. AB TWO SEVEN FOUR
MY NAME IS A LOW MAN I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS MAXINE I SUPPORT EIGHTY P.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
COME ON IN I SUPPOSE AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS
OLIVIA AND I SUPPORT AB. TWENTY
OMAR IT I SUPPORT A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR MY NAME IS TO
MY NAME IS TO BORROW AND I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR MY NAME IS KENNETH AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS SHEILA AND I
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. MY NAME IS JADED MY NAME
MY NAME IS SHANNON AND I SUPPORT
IT. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS PRISCILLA AND I SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS ISRAEL IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS INVASION LAST SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
FANTASTIC AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR MY NAME IS BILL SELECT AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MANAGING AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS KEVIN
AND I SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVEN. MY NAME'S APPARATUS
SUPPORT. TWO TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR MY NAME IS LI AND I SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR MY
NAME IS RYAN I SUPPORT AB.
SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS RALLY AND I SUPPLY AB.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. MONEY
CENTER AND I SUPPORT AB. TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR MY NAME IS
ELENA SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS AMIR
AND I SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS KUMARI
I SUPPORT. AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MARCUS MAN. AND
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS JORDAN
I SUPPORT. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR MY NAME IS MY NAME'S LEYVA
I SUPPORT AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR MY NAME IS CONTROLLING MY
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS TERRENCE AND I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR. MY NAME IS KIMBERLY SMITH
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS SACHIN AN IRON
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS DENISE
CAVALEIRO AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
TAMARA WILLIAMS AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
NICOLE CAME IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS LIN
NAI IN SUPPORT OF AB T. SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS TAYLOR
GRACE. IN SUPPORT OF AB T. SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS JASSIM AL
PATTERSON IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
REANIMATE GAMES IN SUPPORT OF
TWO AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS CASSIDY A DUSTER AND I
SUPPORT. AB. TWO SEVEN ZERO
FOUR. MY NAME IS ELENA BROOKS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS HENRY HENRY I'M
IN SUPPORT. AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS TRUSTING KIDS
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS GYRO
SHAVERS IN SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
SABRINA SAN AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS GLADYS TAMPA'S IN I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS DARREN IN
SUPPORT AND. EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS ALICIA
LACKEY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HOWEVER MONEY
HERE IS. I SUPPORT ABC. TWO FOUR
SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
RAHEL LEILANI I SUPPORT AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHLOE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
SYDNEY WHERE THE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS MILLION I MEAN SUPPORT
FEW OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
HI MY NAME IS DARIUS IN IN- IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN. HI MY
NAME'S EMILIANO I AM IN SUPPORT
OF. AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER I SUPPORT A.
B. TO SEND HIM FOR. HI MY NAME
IS MINE AND I SUPPORT AP. TWO
SEVEN FOUR. HOW MANY EARLY ON
AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. HI MY NAME IS JENNY
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HELLO IN MY NAME IS KEN
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HELLO MY NAME
MASON AND I SO FORD. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. IN THIS CAN AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS JORDAN ARE
SUPPORT A. B. TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
MY NAME IS THE SIZE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. HI
MY NAME IS MEANING I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR. MY NAME
IS ISABEL AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. RIGHT
HAVE TO PLAY AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR MY NAME'S MASS SUPPORT A.
B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS LEON AND I SUPPORT. AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME IS THE
CAIRO I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS NATALIE
AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN
FROM FOR. MY NAME IS THAI REGION
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS DAMIEN. AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
HELLO I AM MY NAME IS JACOB AND
I SUPPORT. EIGHT D. TWO SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS GRINNELL I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS KELLY AND I
SUPPORT AB. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MISS CURTI MISS
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS THE MARIANA AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN ZERO
FOUR. MY NAME IS A MAN I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS JENNA SAY IN SUPPORT OF HEY
IS TO SUPPORT AND AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS AUDREY
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF TWO AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME IS
JULIA AND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ERIC IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS JAMES AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. YES MY NAME IS JOHN REASON%
I SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. ON A MINIMAL CLIENT
AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO SIX
SEVEN SEVEN. MY NAME IS GEORGE
AND I SUPPORT. I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR HI MY NAME IS A
CARE AND I SUPPORT IT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME'S AS
NINE A SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS AMY AND I
SUPPORT AB B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MIKE IN LAST.
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY MAIN
IS ONE AND I SUPPORTER OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS JOE
MONTANA AND I SUPPORT A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
JESSICA PRESENT I SUPPORT AB TWO
NATALIE AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ELAINE I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS MARIA AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MAKAYLA AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS ASSIGNED
I SUPPORT IT. EIGHT MY NAME IS A
CYANIDES IN I SUPPORT AB TWO
SENSIBLE. MY NAME IS JESSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS AMY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS SAMANTHA IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME
IS KIMBERLY AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SUMS OF. MONEY IN TORONTO
AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS NOAH AND
I SUPPORT A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS DON CAN I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS JAY AND I SUPPORT
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
A IS IT FOR EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ISABELLA
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR MY NAME IS A RIDE I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ALONSO LAST FOR AT AB. SEVEN TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. IMPOSING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SOMETHING FOR
. MY NAME IS EMMANUEL IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME. IS SUPPORT OF AB. TWO TWO
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ERIC AND
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SOLUTION
FOR. MY NAME SEVEN AND I. AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THOUSAND. MY
NAME IS ISABEL AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS KIMBERLY I
SUPPORT. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS KEHLANI IN IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. TWO FOUR SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS MAKAYLA AND I ANSWER OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR MY NAME
IS THE MONEY AND I IN IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS LEVINE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF TEAS ABC SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS CARTER AND I
SUPPORT AB SEVEN. SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. I AM REALLY IN ISAAC FOR A
B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM
BRILLIANT AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM VERY AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
ASSEMBLY ON THE EASEL PORTAL I
BASIL'S YET THIS YET THE QUATTRO
. I AM BRILLIANT AND I SUPPORT
A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM
BRILLIANT AND ANY SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM
REALLY A IN OUR SUPPORT A. B.
BRILLIANT AND I SUPPORT A. B.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM VERY
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. I AM BILLION IN OUR
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN ZERO FOUR.
I AM BRILLIANT AND I SUPPORT AB
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM BRILLIANT
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. I'M BRILLIANT AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN FOR
. MY NAME IS CHASE TED I
SUPPORT. A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS CALEB IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS PRINCE TO
MINGLE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
JOSEPH ORTIZ IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVENTY. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MARCUS WALKER
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS ELENA BROWN IN
SUPPORT OF TWO SETS AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS AMIR
JOHNSON IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE FOUR. MY NAME IS LERI
CUFF IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS EMILY ON
A RICHARD ST IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
SHOT A PO IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM BARELY
ENOUGH SUPPORT AB. TWO TWO SEVEN
ZERO FOUR. I AM BILLION US
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. I'M REALLY AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I'M
BRILLIANT AND OUR SUPPORT A. B.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. I AM VERY
AND I SUPPORT TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. I AM REALLY AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR. I AM BRAND
US FOR AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
I AM REALLY SURPRISED A READ IS
THERE ISN'T ONE. I AM REALLY AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. I AM REALLY AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR MY
NAME IS HONOR SOMEONE AND
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS YEAH AND IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN FOUR.
MARLENA'S AMARI AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT A. B. TO SOCIAL FOR. MY
NAME IS KAREN AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT. AB. TWO MY NAME IS
ALEXA AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN. MY NAME IS
EVELYN OUT AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
JEREMIAH AND IN SUPPORT OF AB T.
CENTER CENTER FOR. MY NAME IS-TREASURE EVEN MARIA IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS CASHING BILL IN SUPPORT
NAME IS LAYLA MALARKEY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN FOUR.
ALL I'M ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. NUMBER
THIRTEEN WHO ARE MAY IT BE SEP
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOCUS AUTO. MY
NAME IS COLIN SIMMONS AND I'M
SUPPORTING OF TO SAID AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
LEON HARRIS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TEARS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS KERRISON
MAZA AND I AM IN SPACE SUPPORT
AB TWO STUFF. MY NAME IS AMIR
NINE SUPPORTING A B. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S JOHNNY IN
ON SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS ERICA I AM
REALLY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
NEAR AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS MARIA AND
I'M SUPPORTING AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS PROVIDE
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS DE ANDRE AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS MASON AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS BRANDON I SUPPORT AB. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS OUR
MONEY AND NOT SUPPORT AB TWO
TWOS AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS HE'S GONNA AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
DOOR NOW AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SO FOR. MY NAME IS LONNIE
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVENS OF
WAR. MY NAME IS LESLIE IN AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS MILAN METAPHOR AB
TWO TWO SEVEN FOUR I'M- MY NAME
IS THE WIRELESS SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ARIANNA I SUPPORT AB. TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. MY NAME IS KILEY
AS FOR AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS LUCIANA AS A FOR A B.
TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
MIRACLE AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ALI
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS KEREN I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. I AM BRILLIANT. AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS GIOVANNI YOU'RE SO
BRILLIANT THEY ARE BOILED AB TWO
SEVEN SOME FOUR. MY NAME IS
KAREN AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS JOSEPH
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MARK ON A
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS TASIA AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS IT HONORABLY GUESTS AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWO SEVEN SOME
FOUR. MY NAME IS JAN TEN E. AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. JUST CHOI AND ADNAN THIS
YEP WOULD YOU AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS NIET AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS SAVANNAH IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN ZERO FOUR. MY
NAME IS OMAR AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS RAIN AND I SUPPORT IN AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
FINE AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS SAMUEL IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS MIKE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS DEJAN AND I SUPPORT- AB
TWO TWO DELTA SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
MY NAME IS EMMA- I'M IN SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
CAMERON DECKER AND ALMONDS IN
SUPPORT OF TO BE ON THE AB TWO
CENTS OUT FOR. MY NAME IS
YOLANDA HUDSON AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS HAVING HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SOME
FOUR. MY NAME IS EVELYN MARTINEZ
AND SUPPORT OF AB. TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS DAN WAS
SAN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A KIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS LAURIE GARLIC
IN SO FAR AS TO SOME OF THEM FOR
. MY NAME IS NOURISHMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS TESSA SOLANO
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS CAROL
BURNS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SOME FOUR. MY NAME IS MILAN
POKHARA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ANGELINA POKHARA IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS KENNEDY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ON
IT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
PURCELL IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ROY
WILL HELP AND SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A
CAR MAKERS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN AND I'M SO IN SUPPORT
OF AB TO SOME SOME FOR. MY NAME
IS MILAN AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SERVICE OF FOR. MY NAME IS MIKE
KENNEDY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN TIME FOR. MY NAME IS LUIS
MORENO IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ELIJAH AND I SUPPORT A. B. TWO
TERRY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
COREY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
JUANA SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS LIZA AND I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS ADRIAN I AM SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S
ISLAND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SIMPLE. THAT CAN I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SO FOR. MY NAME'S
ISAAC AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S ALLEN I
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS AND I AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS A LEASE AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS CLAIRE AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. PUT QUICKLY I'M GOING TO
INTERRUPT YOU I THANK YOU TO THE
STUDENTS ARE BEING HERE TODAY
I'M GONNA LEAVE FOR I HAVE A
STATE ALLOCATION BOARD MEETING I
HAVE TO ATTEND. AND THEN I'LL BE
BACK OVER BACK TO THE MID
COMMITTEE BUT IN MY ABSENCE MISS
DOLLY ARE VICE CHAIR WILL TAKE
OVER THE MEETING SO TO MISTER.
GAVEL AND KEEP COMING UP AND
DOING A GOOD JOB. MY NAME'S
ADRIANA. AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME'S RESUME SUPPORT TO
SENSE OF. MY NAME IS I'M RONNIE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVENTHS IMPORT. MY NAME IS
ANDREA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ARIELLE AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
EMILY AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS JADEN I
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS AND SOMEONE GAVE
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IN THE MUD HUTS
AND I SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS MALACHI
HILLS IN AND OUT I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN ZERO FOUR. MY
NAME IS ANTHONY AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
LOUIS AND I SUPPORT A. B. C.'S
TUESDAY SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS RON AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
TRINITY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SOME FOUR. MY NAME IS NO I
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN ZERO
FOUR. MY NAME IS CAMILA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS A NIGHT IN
SUPPORT OF TWO OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS LOUIS AND
S. IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS NATALIA
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS JORDAN IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENS ON FOR
. MY NAME IS TAJ IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS ONE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
DANIEL IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
JULIA GLIDING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
RAVEN ALAN IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ELENA ALLEN IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
RYAN IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS LAUREN IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS DEVIN I SUPPORT
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS JAMES AND I SUPPORT TO AB TWO
SOCIAL FOR. MY NAME IS RICHARD
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS ABBY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF TWO AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS CARRIE
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO SOME OF
SOME OF FOR. MY NAME IS AMY
JACKSON IS A POINT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS ME
TOMORROW AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME
IS SANDY WORKING AND I FEEL VERY
AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR. MY NAME IS
MERRY ALLEN AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. YOUR
CANINE MENTAL FORTITUDE AB TWO
SEVEN SO FOR. MY NAME IS CARLA
CARLA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. NAME IS
NAY MY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
EARL LEVINE SUPPORT. AB TWO
SEVEN ZERO FOUR. MY NAME IS JAY
LOCATED IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A
STORY BILL IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
AVERY NUMBERS BORDERS AB TWO
HOPE JOSEPH IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
MARIE BLAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TO
SAM'S I'M FOR. MY NAME IS
LOOKING HARDEN IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
BRIANNA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. MY NAME IS
AVERY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S AMARI
EWING AND I SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEP BEFORE. MY NAME IS
LIVERMORE'S ENORMOUS APPROPRIATE
B. TWO THOUSAND FOUR. MY NAME IS
ANNA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ABRAHAM LOPEZ AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR. HELLO I
MISS RAY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF A
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR AS WELL. HI
MY NAME IS KAMALA IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. HI
MY NAME IS DESTINY UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS JAY AND I'M
FOUR. MY NAME IS JENNY HOWARD IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVENTH AND
- MY NAME IS NAY WILL BE
RETAINED IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ALLISON DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
JORDAN I SUPPORT AB TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. MY NAME MY NAME IS TERRY
THEN WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME'S
AURORA AND I'M SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS GUADALUPE RODRIGUEZ AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A LAND
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN
TEN POINT. MY NAME IS ALEXANDRIA
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
THAT THE LAWS ON TWO THOUSAND FOUR. MY
NAME IS SEVEN TEN ON THE SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SO FOR. MY NAME
IS JACK CRISTINA I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS CHANTE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS AN S. AND I SUPPORT AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
A MARIANA I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
CHE ONE IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
ADRIAN I AM SUPPORT OF AB
CONSERVATIVE FOR. MY NAME IS
ALONSO THE SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS A
COPING THEM IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
STEVEN I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
JENNA DIA IN I SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN FOOT SEVEN SIMPLE. WHEN
YOU SEE AN IMAGE REPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN. AND I'M SUPPORT OF AB
TWO STEPS UP FOR. MY NAME'S
KATHERINE GARLAND AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME'S ELIZABETH LOPEZ
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY NAME IS
JORDAN I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
AMIR WHY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
TWO AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. MY
NAME IS ALCOHOLISM RAIMES
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. MY NAME IS R. A. SMITH IN
IN SUPPORT OF AB T. SEVEN SO
FOR. MY NAME IS JUDY ONES IS A
POINT OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
. MY NAME IS MARKETS ACTIONS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IT'S GREAT TO
SEE ALL THEIR FACES AND- SO WE
DO NEED TO TAKE ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION. WITH THANK YOU AND
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU LOST ALL OUR
MEMBERS HERE. THAT WE HAD A LOT
OF KIDS PARTICIPATE. SO I WILL I
SUPPORT THIS I SUPPORT IF YEARS
AGO SO I MOVED ON. CAN'T TAKE A
VOTE RIGHT NOW BUT JUST- A
COUPLE ISSUES I THINK THE YOU
SHOULD ADDRESS ABOUT THIS ISSUE-
GOING FORWARD- SO FOUR YEARS AGO
WE PUT THE ALLOCATION IN THE
BUDGET. THERE WAS A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION AND- IT'S SOMEWHAT
UNKNOWN HOW IT WORKS SO HOW DO
YOU RESPOND. HOW DO WE ENSURE.
THAT WE'RE DOING WELL WE SOUGHT
OUT TO DO- USUALLY WHEN WE ARE
WORKING. I USUALLY TO IT'S A
LEAP OF FAITH WE HOPE THAT
SOMEWHERE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
. I'M WAS IMPLEMENTING OUR
VISION OR DOING WORK WE SOUGHT
OUT TO DO IN THE STATE BUDGET.
AND SO WITH THIS IN A PILOT WE
HAD FOR FOUR YEARS. HOW DO WE
SEE WHAT WE SOUGHT TO DO- WORKED
. RIGHT SO I DON'T IT WAS I
DON'T THINK WAS A FOUR YEAR
PILOT I THINK WITH THE ONE TIME
BUDGET COMING OUT WHEN IN THE
BUDGET ONE TIME AS AN ACTIVE
PILOT BECAUSE IT WAS ONE RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT I MEAN. I'M AND ONE
OF THE ISSUES WITH THAT IS. THE
PANDEMIC HEAD. AND SO IT'S
REALLY HARD TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT- THOSE FUNDS REALLY MADE
THE IMPACT THAT WE WERE LOOKING
FOR BUT- I'M SEEING THAT I AM
FOR MY SCIENTIFIC BACKGROUND AND
I DO LIKE TO SEE DATA AND
RESULTS WILL DEFINITELY BE
LOOKING VERY CLOSELY TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THE FUNDS ARE NOT
ONLY GOING WHERE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE GOING AND DOING
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING BUT IF THEY'RE NOT FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO CHANGE
COURSE SO THAT WE CAN START TO
CLOSE. ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
YEAH I THINK. AND I AM. WE HAD
OUR SUPERINTENDENT AS A- PARTNER
WITH THIS. HE WAS- INVOLVED WE
PUT THIS IN THE BUDGET FOR YEARS
AGO. AND IF IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
HE'S HIS- ART OF EDUCATION IS
ENGAGE WITH THIS- BECAUSE IT IS
. YOU KNOW WITHOUT YOU KNOW FIVE
HUNDRED OR SO AMAZING STUDENTS
AND THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
THESE RESOURCES ARE GONNA FOLLOW
THEM TO THEIR CLASSROOM THEY GO
TO A SCHOOL SITE. AND NOW IT'S
UP TO BE ADULTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE FOCUS ON THE RIGHT.
SPOT SO- HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE
THAT WE MAKE THAT HAPPEN YEAH I
THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE WITH LCF
FUNDING OVERALL- AND- AND SO WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE MUCH
MORE ACCOUNTABLE. THESE TO THE
FUNDS AND I AND I THINK THAT'S
JUST BEEN A CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVE JUST THROUGHOUT
THE ASSEMBLY. EVENT ENDING IN
GENERAL. I CAN. LIKE TO CLOSE.
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
SPONSORS- ALL THE SPONSORS AND
ALL THOSE WHO CAME TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD TODAY I ALSO WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS FOR
MAKING THIS BILL A CAUCUS
PRIORITY. A STATE THAT ENSURES
EVERYONE IS ACADEMICALLY SUCCESS
IS THE BENEFIT. SO LET'S DO
WHAT'S RIGHT LET'S DO WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR ALL OF THESE KIDS THAT
SHOWED UP TODAY.MOST OF THEM
FALL INTO THIS LOWEST ACHIEVING
OB SUBGROUP. LET'S PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES TO THOSE THAT CLEARLY
NEEDED. AND FINALLY CLOSE THIS
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND
GIVE EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA
THE FOUNDATION TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
SUCCESS AND POTENTIAL IN THE
FUTURE. I URGE YOUR VOTE AND I
VOTE. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- O'DONNELL. I
VALLEY ARE SENATE CHEN LI
MCCARTY MCCARTY I QUIRK-SILVA.
THOSE ON CALL HOLD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
WHO CAME TODAY. THANK YOU.
A LOT OF. ITEM NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN CHAIR VICE CHAIR
AND- MEMBERS. FINAL BILL I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN A MODEST BILL TO
IMPROVE THE CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY AND
EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE TOOL THANK YOU
I'M I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WILL BE
TAKING AMENDMENTS I'M- WE'VE
BEEN HERE FOR A WHILE TODAY SO
I'M GONNA JUST SKIP TO- OUR-
PEOPLE ARE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
WE HAVE CATHERINE FLORES WHO IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA MUTATION COALITION AT
SUDAN. FOREIGN DOLLARS IT'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF NURSING
AND WELLNESS IN SANTA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. READY A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS KATHERINE FLORES
MARTIN AND I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
MINIMIZATION COALITION AND WE'VE
WORKED WITH THE LEGISLATURE FOR
YEARS. TO CREATE STRONG AND
EFFECTIVE LAWS THE RESULT AND
PROTECTING MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
TEENS AND ADULTS FROM
PREVENTABLE DISEASES. THIS BILL
MAKE SIMPLE CHANGES AND UPDATES
THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S. OR TO MAP NEXT
PUBLIC HEALTH AMER. THIS BILL IS
LOOKING TOWARDS THE FUTURE. IN
ADDITION TO REQUIRING THAT
PROVIDERS WHO ADMINISTER
VACCINES ENTER THAT DATA INTO
THE REGISTRY WE'RE ASKING THAT
THE EXISTING RACE AND ETHNICITY
FEEL BE SELECTED AND ESPECIALLY
SIGNIFICANT EDUCATION. IS THAT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE ACCESS
TO VIEW THE DATA ON ALL DEATHS
IN WAITED TO STUDENT SAFETY.
SURE EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT IS IN THE CASE OF AN
OUTBREAK OF SOMETHING LIKE
HEPATITIS A FOR EXAMPLE
HEPATITIS A VACCINE IS GIVEN AT
AROUND WHEN YOU'RE OF AGE. AND
IT IS A RECOMMENDED BUT NOT
RIGHT HIGHER VACCINATION FOR
SCHOOL. IN THE EVENT OF A LOCAL
OUTBREAK WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR SCHOOL NURSES TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW THE IMMUNIZATION STATUS OF
THEIR- THEIR STUDENTS. OUR NEXT
PANDEMIC MAY NOT BE A NOVEL
CORONAVIRUS A COULD BE A NOVEL
INFLUENZA VIRUS. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE
IN PLACE AND READY TO ADDRESS
FUTURE NEEDS. NOT FIX IT
AFTERWARDS NOT FIX IT IN THE
MIDDLE BE READY FOR THE FUTURE.
FOR THESE UPDATES WILL HELP
ENSURE GREATER EQUITY AND ACCESS
TO VACCINES BY THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN PARTICULARLY HARMED BY THIS
PANDEMIC. FIRST AUTHORIZED. I'M
SORRY THE REGISTRY WAS FIRST
AUTHORIZED IN NINETEEN NINETY
IT'S BEEN A LONG RUN FOR A LONG
TIME AND SINCE THAT. MEANS OF
DOSES AND RECORDED IN THE
REGISTER. AND IT'S BECOME AN
AMAZING RESOURCE FOR THE STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS AND FOR SCHOOLS.
WERE AUTHORIZED USERS. THE
DOCUMENT VACCINE MINISTRATION
AND IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTREACH NEEDS. FOR THE
REGISTRY SYSTEM CONSOLIDATES
IMMUNIZATION RECORDS FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES INTO A SINGLE
RECORD. IT FORECAST WHAT
IMMUNIZATIONS ARE DO IT MANAGES
VACCINE INVENTORY ASSIST
PROVIDERS WITH CONDUCTING
REMINDER RECALL THE SEND OUT
REMINDER NOTICES. AND PRODUCES A
VARIETY OF PATIENT SPECIFIC AN
AGGREGATE REPORTS TO BE ABLE TO
JOBS. AUTHORIZED USERS POLLUTE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOL
AND CHILD CARE FOR SO. THE
ACCESS. CHOIR TO FIND
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS AND
UNDERGO REQUIRED TRAINING. THE
CARE SYSTEM WAS ALREADY IN PLACE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHING IMPORTANT WORK TO
SUPPORT HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS IN SCHOOLS. PUBLIC
HEALTH COMMUNITY AND HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
BEEN USING THIS REGISTRY FOR
DECADES THERE'S NO LEGITIMATE
OFF OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
PROVIDERS ARE HAPPY WITH THE
SYSTEM AND THEY ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPAT THIS LEGISLATION AND
WE ALSO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSAN
BARNES- I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF NURSING AND WELLNESS
IT'S SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IS
THE SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA. WE SERVE
STUDENT POPULATION OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY. THIS YEAH. I NEVER IT'S
QUALIFY FOR A REDUCED LUNCH
MEALS ADDED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
PANDEMIC HAS DEMONSTRATED THE
NEED FOR INFORMATION TO BE
EFFECTIVELY SERVE STUDENTS AND
TO DO IT WITH EQUITY. SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED WE COULD BE AS PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH WHAT THEY NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT. AND HOW THEY
NEED IT. AS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE
FACE AND HELPING OUR MOST
IMPACTED STUDENTS IS KNOWING WHO
HAS ACCESS TO VACCINE AND WHO
DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS TO VACCINES
. ACCESS TO THEIR IT'S CRITICAL
FOR US TO ASSESS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR SCHOOLS AND TO
ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS REMAIN OPEN
EVEN DURING A PANDA. AS WITH
THESE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
THAT CATHERINE OUTLINED CAN YOU
IMAGINE THAT- THERE WAS WAS A
SCHOOL THAT WAS JUST THROUGH
HERE IF JUST ONE STUDENT HAD AN
OUTBREAK OF HEPATITIS EIGHT. OR
WHAT. HOW TO KEEP YOUR COCKLE
MENINGITIS WE WOULD HAVE TO LOOK
UP THE STUDENTS IN. HIGHER
SCHOOLS. THE SCHOOL SO MANY
TIMES WE THINK OF A CLASSROOM
IT'S A LARGE BODY OF STUDENTS
THAT WE HAVE TO RESEARCH REALLY
FAST TO GET THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED. ACCESS STREET DURING A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WILL
ALSO REMOVE THE BURDEN ON
PARENTS. AS THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES
COMMUNICATE WITH SCHOOLS WHEN
THEIR CHILD HAS BEEN VACCINATED.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL SIMPLY
BE ABLE TO CHECK THEIR REGISTRY
ON A REGULAR BASIS TO CONFIRM A
STUDENT HAS BEEN VACCINATED.
THIS IS ALSO CRITICAL FOR
HOMELESS AND FOSTER CARE
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT ALWAYS BE
AWARE NEED TO INFORM THEIR
SCHOOL ABOUT THEIR VACCINATION
STATUS OR TO ACCESS VACCINE. FOR
THESE REASONS DIEGO UNIFIED IS A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. AND THANKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND AUTHORIZING THIS
PROPOSAL. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU AYE VOTE ON AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TODAY. OH
I'M SORRY. RIGHT ANY SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM.
MEDICAL DEVICE CHEN MEMBERS
pDENNIS QUESTO MATTER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY KING ON BEHALF
OF PROTECT US IN STRONG SUPPORT
. ALYSON WAY ON BEHALF OF
PROTECT US IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRODERICK'S OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
HELD RENDON I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE VOICE TO TRACE ADVOCACY
WELL WE AGREE IMPROVEMENTS NEED
TO BE MADE TO THE CALIFORNIA
MINIMIZATION REGISTRIES THE BILL
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS HONESTLY THE
REGISTRIES A MASS FOR EXAMPLE
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT. THERE
ARE. BILLS HAVING. RECORD THIS
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED THE
CALIFORNIA AND MONETIZATION
REGISTRIES CLAIM TO BE OPT OUT
REGISTRIES BUT THEY ONLY
ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR THE LOOKING
AT THE DATA WITH ALL THE
REMAINING DATA LEFT IN THE
SYSTEM CURRENTLY MOST VACCINE
PROVIDERS INPUT VACCINES INTO
THE REGISTRIES DO. OVER TO OLD
TO DO SO WHEN THEY DO THEY
DISCLOSE THAT THEY'RE DOING SO
TO THE PATIENT PARENTS GUARDIANS
BUT IS VACCINATED CANNOT DO
ANYTHING TO STOP THE IT A
DISAGREED WELL MAY. HAPPY ONE
WHERE THEY CAN GET OUT ALL THEIR
VACCINE. WE'VE RECEIVED NUMEROUS
CONCERNED BECAUSE IN FROM UNTUK
FAMILIES AND THOSE CONCERNED FOR
THE PRIVACY OF THEIR MEDICAL
RECORDS NOT WANTING THEM TO BE
SAVED IN A GOVERNMENT DATABASE.
THESE GROUPS WOULDNOT BE
VACCINATE THEM DATA AND
INTERGOVERNMENTAL TO BASE TO
NOTE THESE PATIENTS WOULD STILL
EASY ACCESS THE VACCINE- THREE
THAT POSITION. THANK FOR THE K.
WHEN YOU TAKE PRIVACY QUESTION
MEDICAL RECORDS VERY SERIOUSLY.
YOUR COMMITTEE TO THE RED TO BE
PICKED. INSTANT IS A RECORDS OR
INPUT THE TIME BACKS IN A- WE
APPRECIATE THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMEND BUT AN ISSUE
WITH THE SUGGESTION. CASE OF
SCHOOLS LIMIT THE T. OF SCHOOLS
TO DOWNLOAD THE CODE NINETEEN
VACCINE INFORMATION INTO THOSE
SCHOOLS WITH A POLICY MANDATING
COVERT NINETEEN MAXINE'S THERE
COULDN'T BE NO PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT ARE MANDATING THE COBIT
NINETEEN VACCINE AS A RESULT OF
LAWSUITS AGAINST INDIA UNIFIED
AND PENA BONTA I SCHOOL TO.
WHERE THE JOB RULED THAT MANDATE
. CURRENTLY STATUTES THAT CAN
ONLY BE DONE BY PH OR THE- IF
EITHER OF THOSE ENTITIES WERE TO
MANDATE THE CARPET NINETEEN
VACCINES SCHOOL OR TO. HAVE
ACCESS. FOR THE OTHER SCHOOL
REQUIRED VACCINES MAKING THIS
SECTION OF THE BILL REDUNDANT
WITHOUT COULD BE NINETEEN
VACCINE MANDATES IT'S ALSO
UNCLEAR WHY WHICH CAO WAX AND
OTHER ENTITIES LISTED IN THE
BILL WE NEED ACCESS TO THE CODE
NINETEEN VACCINE INFORMATION
THANK. ASKING POSE A. B. SEVENTY
NINETY SEVEN BUT IF YOU FEEL THE
NEED TO VOTE AND MOVE THIS BILL
TODAY WE ASK YOU DO SO WITH ME
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. RACHEL
IVERMECTIN GATES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
BUT I DID SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
VERONICA FROM THE YUBA COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. SURE IN A LATCH PLASTER
COUNTY IN A REPRESENT JAMES P.
BRAWLEY RUNNING FOR US SENATE
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL. QUINTON AVEC ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS
RECORDING NO COMMENTS. IT'S WE
HAD A MOTIONS AGAIN FOR THIS
BILL. NOW. SO I WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE SAY SO I CAN'T MAKE
THE SECOND BUT I DO HAVE- I
RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF CALLS AND
EMAILS FROM CONCERNED SAID- CAN
TWINS AND ONE OF THE BIG MOST I
GUESS. I GUESS PERCENTAGES
PROTECTING THEIR DATA THEIR
CHILD'S MEDICAL INFORMATION SO I
THINK TO CLARIFY FOR MYSELF I
READ THROUGH THE BILL. IT IS THE
INTENT SCHOOL SITE TO BE ABLE TO
. LOOK UP OKAY I'LL HAVE YOU
ANSWER LOOK UP THE THEIR
INFORMATION FOR THEIR SCHOOL SO
OF IS EXAMPLE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
BUT IT IS THAT THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED GOING TO BE ABLE TO THEN
LOOK INTO LA IN A FIVE OR A
NEIGHBORING SCHOOL BUT- IS. COOL
RIGHT. YEAH SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
WOULD ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
OWN STUDENTS. I DON'T KNOW THAT
SO THE YOUNG MAN ON TO THAT SO
THE DATABASE ALREADY EXISTS.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
PROVIDERS USE THE SYSTEM IT'S
BEEN AUTHORIZED FOR MANY YEARS
IT'S HAD NO DATA BREACHES
THERE'S NOTHING TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS WOULD HAPPEN IT'S AS IF.
WE'RE PUTTING IN THE YELLOW CARD
INFORMATION THE INFORMATION ON
VACCINE RECORDS THERE'S NO OTHER
MEDICAL INFORMATION IN THERE
THAT WOULD. THE SOMETHING THAT
SOMEBODY WOULD WANT TO ACCESS
THERE'S NO REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT WOULD HAPPEN BUT- SO. BASIS
THERE ARE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
TO ACCESS I GET MY TO MY SON
GETS HIS VACCINATION AND FRESNO
MAYBE WE MOVED TO SAN DIEGO
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO LOOK THAT UP
THERE ARE FIVE IS MY YELLOW CARD
ALONG THE WAY SO THE CHILD
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE. RE
VACCINATED THE SCHOOL NURSES CAN
LOOK UP THAT DATA AS WELL ON THE
STUDENTS AT THEIR SCHOOL. SO
YEAH IT IT'S OPEN TO PEOPLE WHO
RIDE BY LAW TO UPDATE NOW WE'RE
OR IS TO FIRST SCHOOLS WILL TO.
BUT TECHNICALLY SCHOOLS CAN ONLY
LOOK LOOK AT TECHNICALLY ON THE
LOOK AT. THE REQUIRED
VACCINATIONS THAT'S WERE HERE
ABOUT. NOT NOT TO AND WE'RE NOT
HERE TO ALLOW OF REGISTRY THAT'S
THAT'S- THAT'S ALLOWED THAT'S
HEARING THAT THAT'S DONE. WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT IS ALLOWING
SCHOOLS TO LOOK ALL THE DATA TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK AT. MANY COCKLE
BACK DOES NOT OFFER. SCHOOLS
TECHNIQUE LOOK AT UP THEY CAN'T
LOOK. HEPATITIS A RIGHT NOW THEY
CAN SEE ALL THE OTHER VACCINE
BUT THEY CAN'T. TECHNICALLY USE
THAT DATA. TO DETERMINE HOW TO
DO OUTREACH IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO THIS ISN'T ABOUT. WHETHER
DISTRICTS EXIST. YES THAT'S
ABOUT GIVING HER. A TO LOOK AT
WHAT THEY NEED TO PREVENT
DISEASE AND OUR SCHOOLS. SO-
THERE'S A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
DISINFORMATION OUT THERE ABOUT
THIS I REGISTRY SIDE I WILL
HIGHLIGHT A FEW THINGS THAT I
WAS A IGHT TALKING POINTS BUT
WE DID THIS YESTERDAY. WE HAVE
HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE SPEAKING I'M
SO LIKE WAS STATED THIS
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY CAME INTO
EXISTENCE. MANY YEARS AGO WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES LATE NINETEEN NINETIES.
I'M IT BEGAN WITH A LOT OF MANY
DIFFERENT INDEPENDENT COUNTY
BASED SYSTEMS AND HAS BEEN
UPGRADED TO A MORE CENTRALIZED
STATE WIDE DATABASE. TODAY EVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA IS A PART
OF THIS SYSTEM EXCEPT SAN
JOAQUIN WHO HAS ITS OWN
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY THE WERE
NOT CREATING ANYTHING NEW WE'RE
NOT BRINGING IN ANY BY NEW THE
MAJORITY OF COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE A PART OF ITS
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY. CURRENTLY
EIGHTY SIX CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE AGE OF SIX
HAVE TWO OR MORE IMMUNIZATIONS
ALREADY IN THIS REGISTRY. I'M
EXISTING LAW ALSO ALLOWS THE
IMMUNIZATION INFORMATION TO BE
SHARED WITH THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY AS LONG AS THE PATIENT
OR THE PARENT IS INFORMED ABOUT
THAT REGISTRY IF THEY DON'T WANT
IT THEY CAN ALWAYS LOCK THEIR
RECORDS SO THAT IT IS NOT SHARED
WITH ANY OTHER USER SO THAT THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM CAN'T SEE IT ON
AND THAT THEIR FOOD GEN IT IT IT
JUST LIKE AND THEIR- ON A-
CORPORATE UNIT. BUT YOUR DOCTORS
DON'T WRITE IT ON PAPERS. MOST
OF US DON'T. MOST OF US USE
ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD SYSTEM
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE IT BUT OTHER
USERS ONE THAT. THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRIES I ESTATUA SHORE
STRICT CONFIDENCE. TYPICA AND A
WOMAN AND TWO PER. OR TO BE A
USER THE PROVIDER USER MUST SIGN
A CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENT AND
VIEWING OF PATIENT RECORDS ARE
TRACKED AND MAINTAINED WITH AN
AUDIT TRAIL. IF YOU HAPPEN TO GO
INTO SOMETHING THAT YOU
SHOULDN'T YOU WILL BE FLAGGED.
ON ANOTHER QUESTION THAT WE HAD
YESTERDAY WAS WHETHER OR NOT
THERE HAS BEEN LIKE ANY BREACHES
AND THE AND THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRIES SINCE IT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
NOW SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN THERE IT'S SAFE IT DOES NOT
VIOLATE HIPPA LAWS- IF THE ONLY
THING IS THAT NOT ALL PROVIDERS
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE IN A SMALL
PRIVATE PRACTICE SOMEWHERE YOU
MAY NOT ACTUALLY BE INPUTTING
THAT INFORMATION INTO THE SYSTEM
BUT IT'S TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
REALLY SHOULDN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO CARRY AROUND DIGITAL
CARDS THAT WERE IN EXISTENCE
WHEN I WAS A AND- BECAUSE WE
HAVE PASSED IT BOB THEY'RE NOT.
OTHER METAL PRACTICES AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IMMUNIZATION DATABASE IS. MODERN
AND ACCURATE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHEN INTO THE YES TO
ME. THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M I
THINK THERE IS A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN WHAT THE SUPPORT SIDE IS
AYING WHAT THE BILL DOES AND
WHAT ARE WHAT SOME PEOPLE'S
UNDERSTANDING IS AND I THINK THE
DISCONNECT THERE IS THERE A
CONVERSATION BY THE SUPPORT SIDE
THE THAT A DISTRICT. SORT OF
DOWNLOAD OR ACCESS YOU KNOW
THERE DISTRICTS DATA SO OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT CURRENTLY
ALL THAT YOU CAN DO IN THE CARE
IT. POSTED DATE THAT'S WHAT CAN
DOWN. THERE SAYING THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE A THAT THEY WANT TO
KNOW THE MAN CHOCOLATE WHATEVER
IT THE I BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS
OF THE BILL FROM THIS PREMISE
COMMITTEE ONLY WOULD RESTRICT IT
TO COVE IT BUT I THINK THERE IS
A CONNECT ON. IN FOR AND WHETHER
THE JUDGE. AS TO BEING ABLE TO
DOWNLOAD LARGE SWATHS OF DATA ON
YOUR WHOLE SCHOOL DISTRICT AT
ONCE AND THAT'S THE QUESTION
THAT WE WOULD LOVE ANSWERED AS
WELL. THANK YOU AND I THINK WE
HAVE SOMEONE HERE THE IMITATION
REGISTER. IS THE ACT EXPERT AND
- WHEN YOU WANT TO BE A FEW SO.
MOVEMENT- THE DATA IS AVAILABLE
TO THE SCHOOLS NOW IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALSO AS YOU MAY KNOW
HAVE THEIR OWN DATABASES SO THIS
THIS MANY TIMES THE STATE
ALREADY EXISTS IN THE SCHOOL
DATABASE. SO IT'S A IT'S PART OF
THE STUDENTS RECORDS RIGHT NOW
SUSAN CAN EXPAND ON THIS OF. YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU PARENT THE PARENT
PRESENTS OUR CHILD FOR ENTRY
INTO SCHOOLS A KINDERGARTNER NEW
STUDENT CALLUM THEY PER MANY OF
THE DOCK YELLOW MERGERS WILL
RECORD AND THAT IS PUT IN. THE
SCHOOL RECORD THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION RECORD ALONG WITH
THE OTHER STUDENT DATA. EIGHT
NURSES AND CAN USE TO VERIFY NEW
VACCINATIONS THAT MAY NOT HAVE
MADE IT ONTO THE SCHOOL DATABASE
SO IT'S A SECOND TOOL I'M- THIS
MEANT THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
DISCUSSED SWATHS OF DATA BEING
DOWNLOADED BUT IT IS USED FOR
SCHOOL ENTRY FOR SCHOOL
PURPOSES- DOCTORS CAN WRITE
REPORT ON THEIR PATIENTS. THE
STATE CAN RUN REPORTS IN PROJECT
. NO IDENTIFYING INFORMATION SO
IT IS NOT CORRECT TO SAY THAT
MASSES OF DOWNLOADS WILL BE
OCCURRING. IT'S ONLY AS
APPROPRIATE FOR SCHOOL OR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER AS DR WEBER SAID-
THINGS ARE FLAGGED IT'S A IF
IT'S NOT BEING IT'S NOT IF IT'S
WITH MONITOR CLOSE. AT AT IN.
STUDENTS FROM ALL OVER REGISTER
FOR SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
MANY MANY TIMES THEY'VE JUST
REMOVED I IN THEIR SHOP RECORD.
AND SO WE NEED A DATABASE TO BE
ABLE TO GO IN AND QUICKLY FIND
THEIR SHOT RECORD OTHERWISE THEY
CAN'T LEGALLY ENROLL FOR SCHOOL.
AND THEN THEY GO HOME AND TRY TO
FIND OR YOU'VE GOT A FAMILY
WHO'S GOT LOSE WHAT OVER IT.
YOU'VE GOT A HOMELESS OR- YOU
DIDN'T. OF AN END TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS A CENTRALIZED SYSTEM FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND IN
TERMS OF YEP BIG SWATHS I MEAN I
CAN ONLY THINK OF WHEN WE HAVE.
OUT CASES THE BIG SUAS IT'S
SPECIFIC TO THE STUDENTS THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN CLOSE KIND WITH. AS WHEN A
CAR YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS JUST YES YES YES I
HAVE ACCEPTED THE MMA KQ EIGHT
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY PLEASE CALL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I'M SORRY OH SORRY I KEEP
MISSING THE CLOSED PART. YEAH I
JUST SAY THIS- IT IT UPDATES ARE
ALREADY EXISTING IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY DOES NOT VIOLATE ANY
CAPITALIZED OR DOES IT REMOVE A
PATIENT PARENTS RIGHT TO DECLINE
TO HAVE INFORMATION. FROM BEING
ACCESSED FROM ANY OF THE OTHER
USERS AND IRIS. IT'S CALLED.
FILE ITEM NINE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL DOLLY
NO VALLEY KNOW BENNETT. CHEN
PLEASE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I'D.
WELL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MISTER VEHICLE WHAT. FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB TWO EIGHT ZERO SIX ZERO
FOUR- SB AB TWO ZERO FOUR TWO.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
AND THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AND IMMENSE
AB TWENTY FORTY TWO. PRESCHOOL
AWARENESS FOR SIGNS OF SYMPTOMS
OF ANAPHYLAXIS. A SERVIR AND PUT
UP POTENTIALLY LIFE THREATENING
ALLERGY REACTION IN IN CHILD
CARE SETTINGS INFANTS AND
TODDLERS ARE PARTICULARLY AT
RISK. AS THE RATE ADDED THE
LEXUS IS MUCH HIGHER AMONG THIS
AGE GROUP ADD WITH PROPER
TRAINING RECOGNIZING THE SIGNS
OF SYMPTOMS GAD PROVE MORE TO.
THE TRAINING PULLOUT COMPELLED
BY AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO IS A
SIMPLE ENHANCEMENT TO THE FIRST
AID FIRST AID CPR TRAINING ONE
MIGHT BE. CONDITION ONCE LICENSE
. THE BILL ENSURES THAT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WILL HAVE THE
BEST PRACTICE POLICIES IN IN
PLACE TO PREVENT ANAPHYLAXIS THE
TRAINING TO RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS AND- ANY AT. ELECT
THICK EVEN OCCUR THE CDVA
CAPACITY TO TREAT K. TWELVE
STUDENTS ARE ALREADY OF THE
PROTECTION FROM ANAPHYLAXIS WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THE MOST
VULNERABLE. PATIENTS THAT BEAN.
FATHERS ARE FAR OUR AFFORDED TO
THE SAME NGUYEN BEING CARED FOR
H. CAL KERR SAID HE- WITH ME
TODAY TO DEFAULT ON AB TWENTY
FORTY TWO IT UP. YOUR A MEMBER
OF NATALIE GEORGIE SUNSHINE
FOUNDATION AND KATHY. THREE
WALLS RE WALL WA PRE ROLL ONE MY
FAVORITE ACTOR YEAH WITH THE
ASTHMA AND ALLERGY FOUNDATION OF
AMERICA.
YEAH THE BUTTON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LOUIS GEORGIE AND I'M
THE PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF
THE NATALIE GEORGIE SUNSHINE
FOUNDATION. OUR FOUNDATION WAS
ESTABLISHED IN MEMORY OF OUR
DAUGHTER WHO DIED TRAGICALLY
CAMP SACRAMENTO. IN JULY TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AFTER EATING A
RICE KRISPY TREAT THAT SHE THAT
HAD UNDISCLOSED PEANUT BUTTER IN
IT. SHE WAS THIRTEEN GOAL. AS A
PHYSICIAN. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PREVALENCE OF LIFE THREATENING
FOOD ALLERGIES HAS. RISEN FOR
MYRIAD OF REASONS OVER THE LAST
FEW DECADES. MANY OF THESE
CHILDREN IN CHILD CLICK CHILD
CARE ARE LIKELY UNDIAGNOSED
GIVEN THEIR YOUNG AGE. THIS IS A
CONCERN FOR EVERY PARENT AND
EVERY CHILD CARE ST STE SAID IN
SETTING. THESE CHILDREN MAY NOT
YET BE EXPOSED TO THE SPECIFIC
ALLERGEN OR MAY JUST NOT HAVE
YET BEEN DIAGNOSED. FOOD ALLERGY
STATUS CAN CHANGE THIS CONCERN
IS SOMETHING THE PROCESS FOR ALL
THESE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. SINCE WE LOST NATALIE.
OUR FAMILY HAS WORKED TO MAKE
THINGS SAFER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. WE WERE HONORED BOARD
SB TWELVE SIXTY SIX INTRODUCED
BY THEN SENATOR BOB HUFF. WHICH
ALLOWED FOR UNDESIGNATED EPIC
EPINEPHRINE IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE ADVOCATED FOR
RESTAURANT LEGISLATION THAT
ADDRESSED FOOD ALLERGIES AND
INCLUDED CAMPUS DINING STAFF TO
BE TRAINED IN FOOD ALLERGY
SAFETY. THAT LEGISLATION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT PROPER CARE
CAN IS KNOWN AS NATALIE'S LAW.
THIS OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR FOOD
ALLERGY LEGISLATION IN THE PAST.
WE KNOW THAT THIS SUPPORT WILL
CONTINUE BECAUSE THESE BILLS
SAVE LIVES. ALISA IS TRAGIC
DEATH. EXPOSE VULNERABILITIES IN
ALLERGY AWARENESS AND TRAINING
IN NEW YORK STATE'S CHILD CARE
SETTINGS BUT IT ALSO EXPOSED TO
WEAKNESS IN CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES IN A GAP THAT WE MUST
FILL. NATALIE'S PICTURE. ALONG
WITH ALISA YOUR WITNESS TO THE
DANGERS OF FOOD ALLERGIES.
PLEASE NEVER LET US ALLOW THE
PICTURE OF ANOTHER PERSON'S
CHILD. WHOSE LIFE HAS BEEN TAKEN
BY FOOD ALLERGIES TO BE PLACED
ON THIS TABLE. ON BEHALF OF OUR
- AND ARTS CENTER AND- WE ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO WORK TO PASS
THIS COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION
ALLIES IS LAW TO CLOSE THAT GAP
AND MAKE IT SAFER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY I'M CATHY PRESS FOR A VICE
PRESIDENT COMMUNITY FOR THE
ASTHMA AND ALLERGYFOUNDATION OF
AMERICA OR AFRICA. AND ALSO A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT ON BEHALF OF
ALPHA AND THE MORE THAN TWELVE
THIRTY TWO MILLION AMERICANS
LIVING WITH THREATENING FOOD
ALLERGIES. I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS OFFERS STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FORTY TWO OR LARGEST
LAW.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EVEN THOUGH
THE CHILD CARE FACILITY HAD
DOCUMENTATION OF A LARGE AS LIFE
THREATENING MILK ALLERGY. HE WAS
FED UP BUT SHE SANDWICH.
FACILITY DID NOT HAVE EMERGENCY
ANAPHYLAXIS PROTOCOL TO FOLLOW.
NEARLY ONE IN TEN CHILDREN HAS A
FOOD ALLERGY IN INFANTS AGES
ZERO FOUR HAVE A HIGHER RATE
THAN OTHER AGE GROUPS. AS A
PARENT. CHILD TO SOMEONE ELSE'S
CARE IS HARD. IF THEY HAVE A
LIFE THREATENING FOOD ALLERGIES
IT CAN BE TERRIFYING. I WILL
NEVER FORGET THE DAY I GOT THAT
CALL THAT MY THREE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER. GET HER OUT. BOB SUBS
AITOR PRESCHOOL WHEN SHE. THREE
MY HEART SANK AS THE TEACHER WAS
FRANTIC AND DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO THEY HAD NO PROTOCOLS AND NO
TRAINING. MORE THAN TWENTY- NOT
MUCH HAS CHANGED. ACTUALLY THE
MISTAKE WAS CAUGHT BEFORE MY
DAUGHTER ATE THAT FOOD. A LOT ON
CALIFORNIA WOULDAPPLY IMPORTANT
POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING
REQUIREMENTS ALL DAY CARE
PROVIDERS PROVIDERS WOULD HAVE
TO TAKE CONCRETE STEPS TO MANAGE
FOOD ALLERGIES FOR THE CHILDREN
IN THEIR CARE INCLUDING
DEVELOPING EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS
PLANS FOR PREVENTING EXPOSURE.
PLANTS APPROPRIATE MENTORS
SHOULD ANAPHYLAXIS OCCUR.
EPINEPHRINE IS THE ONLY
TREATMENT FOR ANAPHYLAXIS YOUNG
WITH FOOD ALLERGIES MEDIA ACCESS
TO EPINEPHRINE. MR BY A TRAIN
ADULT FOR THE TRIP PROP
TREATMENT ABOUT BLACK. THE YOUNG
. SUPPORT CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN
NEW YORK ILLINOIS VIRGINIA AND
PASSING A LARGE IS LAW TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN TO PREVENT
ANOTHER TRAGEDY LIKE A LARGE IS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TOO MANY
CHILDREN WITH THE G. STILL LACK
THE NECESSARY PART IN TO GROW
AND THRIVE IN THE CHILD CARE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK. THERE ANY
OTHERS. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR TO MADDEN REPRESENT MYSELF
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AND URGE
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU. KIMBERLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
WE ARE NOT QUITE TO SUPPORT BUT
WE'RE REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE- LEAPS AND BOUNDS THIS BILL
IS TAKEN WE THINK I'D SCORE IT
HAS. REALLY GOOD WE WILL CAN
WORKING ON A BILL MOVE FOR. WE
DO NEED TO TIGHTEN UP SOME
LANGUAGE AROUND THE ABILITY FOR-
THE WORK FORCE TO BE COMPENSATED
FOR THEIR TRAINING AND SKILL SET-AS WELL AS- THE LIABILITY ISSUES
OUT IN TRANSLATION PAUL SMITH-
WE- DID TO. WOODWORK WELL IT IS.
THINK YOU. YOU ME- POSSESS.
NAVNEET PER YEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION UNFORTUNATELY HERE
AND AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEM IMMENSELY ADDRESS MOST OF
THE CONCERNS HOWEVER WE STILL
HAVE CONSERVANCY OF REGARDING
AMBIGUITY NO LIABILITY
PROTECTION SECTION SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MIGHT OFFER A
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES STIPENDS AS
AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
ADMINISTER MEDICATION HOWEVER
WITH THE CURRENT WORDING OF THE
LIABILITY PROTECTION SOME MAIN.
OKAY I ABILITY PROTECTION THE
STATE. I AND WE'RE JUST HOPING
TO TIGHTEN UP THAT LANGUAGE
THANK YOU THIS CHAIR COULD COULD
I ASK THE- WHO ASK THE PERSON
FOR. THE OF THE QUESTION.
WHOEVER EVER HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO ANSWER MY QUESTION RIGHT.
IT'S YOU'RE GOING TO ASK THE
QUESTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I. I SAW EARLY THAT
DID THAT YOU HAD OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED AND MY QUESTION FOR YOU
WAS THERE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS MADE HERE SO YOU'RE
SAYING THOSE AMOUNTS OF
ADDRESSED. STILL HAVE A FEW. YOU
JUST HAVE BEEN REAL CONCERT
WHILE TENETS OF REGARDING THE
LIABILITY FOR WE HEARD FOR MESSY
I USE THAT THAT THEY ARE NOT
QUITE READY TO SAY YES BUT
THEY'RE OKAY WITH THIS MOVING
FORWARD IS THAT THE POSITION
THAT YOU HAVE IS IT OKAY IF THIS
MOVES FOR. L. THE THEY CONTINUE
TO WORK YOU TO TRY ADDRESS FOR
THE FOR THINGS THAT YOU YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF I MAY
QUICKLY I THINK THERE'S SOME
AMBIGUITY REGARDING- THE LIVES
OF THE ISSUE THAT MAYBE WE GET A
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS AROUND
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT'S BEEN
SOLVED IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS
CLEARLY SOME DON'T. BUT THOSE
WILL BE CONVERSATIONS OBSERVER
THE CHAIR FOR THE- THE AUTHOR
WOULD BE WILLING TO HAVE GOING
FOR. TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
ANY FOR THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. IS BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I WITHOUT I JUST- I
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL MISTER
VIA VOTER- I GATHER TWO KEY
ISSUES WHEN THESE THINGS COME UP
AS WE SEE IT EVERY TIME I
LIABILITIES LIABILITY TO THE
EMPLOYEE. LIABILITY TO THE- AND
THEN TRAINING. RIGHT GIVEN
EXAMPLE TRAIN RIDE I WANT TO
BACK THIS UP THIS FALL THE SAN
JOSE WELL DON'T YOU CAN'T SUB
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T TAKE THIS AB
WHATEVER TRAINING. IT WAS FOUR
HOURS ONLINE ON MY OWN TIME.
RIGHT SO. YOU KNOW THAT'S AND
WHEN WE HAVE TRAINING WHEELS
TRAINING WHEELS TRAINING BILLS
HOWEVER WELL MEANING THERE
PRETTY SOON. YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
FIFTY HOURS OF TRAINING. BEFORE
YOU CAN EVEN GET A KID IN THE
CLASSROOM. AND THAT THAT THAT'S
ON THE K. TWELVE NOW THIS IS A
PARTICULARLY AIMED AT. BUT- YOU
KNOW THIS IS A THIS IS A GREAT
EVER THIS YOU KNOW THIS IS
NICOLE. HEY THIS IS ABOUT YOU
KNOW TRAGIC SITUATIONS WE WANT
TO DRESS- JUST MAKE SURE WE WORK
THIS. OUT THERE. WILL THROUGH
THE PROPER- SO WITH THAT IS
THERE ANY COMMON. I DO A IT IN
IN MY STEP AS WE WERE TRYING TO
REACH THIS STAFF. WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF JUST- JUST TODAY
WE IDENTIFIED WHAT WE THINK IS-
THE NEED NOT. WE HAVE THE
EMPLOYEE COVERED ISSUES WITH
LIABILITY BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
ORGANIZATION COVERED IN TERMS OF
LIABILITY. SO I CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT THERE'S A COMMITMENT OF BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND BY THE
OFFICER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE. THE ORGANIZATIONS
LIABILITIES SCHOOL DISTRICT-
ALSO COVERED AT. I THIS IS A
VALUABLE THING IS WANNA MAKE
SURE WE DO IT RIGHT BUT A- MALL
THERE FOR DOING IT JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO IT RIGHT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO. THE OFFICER
WILL BE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
WORKING. THE ORGANIZATIONS
LIABILITY ALSO RIGHT THANK YOU.
TO SAY YES YEAH I DO NOT HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS- WITHOUT ANY
OTHER FOR THE CRITICALLY COP.
SAYING NO FURTHER COMMITTEE
COMMENT DO WE HAVE A MOTION. MR
MCCARTY MOVES. THE DAILY SECONDS
. OKAY SO IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I'D- THE
FATHER FOR- YEAH OBVIOUSLY I
DIDN'T EXPERIENCED THE TRAGIC.
BUT I DID HAVE ONE THAT DIED AT
THE REALLY BAD. ALERT BUT SHE
WAS UNDER MY CARE. AND I
SUCCESSFULLY WE GOT THROUGH- SO
WE LEAVE OUR KIDS SOMETIMES
ESPECIALLY AS THERE APPEAR
REALLY FOR KIDS WITH OTHER FOLKS
THAT ARE TAKING CARE OF THEM WE
WANT TO WE WANT TO ASSURE WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
AT ALL I'M TRYING TO DO. THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN- OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW IT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO THEM.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE LIFE
BETTER SAFER. TO KEEP KEEPER
KIDS ALIVE. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. RIGHT THIS
CALL THE ROLL. I'LL ADAM EIGHT
AB TWENTY FORTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
MADONNA AYE DALLY. ALLEY I'VE
DONE IT BY BENNETT I CHEN.
PLEASE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA BURKE SURVIVE. THE
BILL HAS FIVE ALSO IT IS OUT
THANK IS OUT WILL MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO MISTER
MCCARTY FILE ITEM NUMBER. TWELVE
AB.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A MUCH OF
A VOICE MUCH ENERGY NEAR PASSED
THE MY BASS IS AWESOME BILL IF
YOU WANT TO BE I LIKE THE EXIST
A LOT OF THESE THINGS THAT'S
OKAY TOO AND LIKE THE- DONALD
LOVE FROM TWO HOURS AGO- NO. I
TO ACCEPT THE COMEDIAN AND- FOR
WORKING WITH US. NO WE KNOW THIS
IS AN ISSUE FOR BOTH- KIDS AND
ALSO FOR PARENTS THE- AB. ALL
DAY VERSUS PART DAY KINDERGARTEN
WE'VE STEPPED UP IN THE BUDGET
LAST FEW YEARS TO TRY TO. HAVE
MORE- SCHOOLS OFFER FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN NOT FULL DAY FULL
SCHOOL DAY LIKE YOU HAVE YOUR
FIRST AND SECOND THIRD GRADE. SO
THIS IS A GOOD COMPROMISE PHASES
IN A PROCESS WHERE. ALL SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE AT LEAST ONE CLASSROOM
AT THEIR SCHOOL SITE OFFERING
FULL SCHOOL DAY. KINDERGARTEN
WITH ME TO TESTIFY OUR LOCAL
PARENT IN FRED RIVAS WITH AT
YOUR- SOMEONE GO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M BRIAN RIVAS ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST UP YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
DOES A GREAT JOB OF PULLING UP
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS FOR
STUDENTS- COGNITIVE GROWTH MATH
SKILL DEVELOPMENT LEARNING DON'T
WORK AND PLAY WITH ONE ANOTHER
ALL THOSE ARE GREAT BENEFITS
THAT SET STUDENTS UP FOR SUCCESS
THEIR FOUNDATIONAL THING I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IS IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE FISH PER
STUDENT WHO. HAVE NOT HAD A THIS
CALL WILL GRANT EARLY MEANS
EIGHTEEN TALKING LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. SO WITH THIS IS AN M.
S. IMPORTANT BILL FOR THOSE- I'M
DOING POPULATIONS. ALSO BENEFIT
FOR STATE FOR FAMILIES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BECAUSE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN RELIEVES THE FAMILY
OF THE COST AND BURDEN OF
MANAGING CHILD CARE. ELEAZAR
PRETTY FUNDED FOR A FULL DAY
PROGRAM WE THINK IT'S TIME FOR.
THE STATE GET THE RETURN ON THAT
INVESTMENT THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
VERY HEALTHY INVESTMENT IN
SCHOOL FACILITIES OVER THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS. SO THOSE
ARE THOSE WITH THE- BILL.
SHINDAND PERSONALLY FOR EDUCATE
MEDICAL SURGERY BOTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON IT WAS CHRISTINA AND
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY
IS. A FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN BILL
AB ONE NINE SEVEN THREE. I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN MY YOUNGEST IS
STILL AN INFANT MY OLDEST IS
CURRENTLY IN KINDERGARTEN.
HAVING ACCESS TO A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN HAS MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN OUR PANELISTS
LACKS. IT'S BEEN A LIFESAVING
CROESOR FOR MEAT MAIN INCOME
EIFFEL TIME JOB. LIKE MOST
WORKING MOTHERS I DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE PICK UP MY- WAIT FOR THE
WAR. FOR KINDERGARTEN HAS READ
YOU MY FAMILY'S FINANCIAL BURDEN
CHILD CARE IS SO EXPENSIVE IN
CALIFORNIA FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
MEANS I DON'T HAVE TO PAY FOR
ASK MANY HOURS OF CARE.
PREVIOUSLY I HAD TO PICK UP MY
CHILD AT TWELVE PM AND THIS MADE
MAINTAINING MY ON A FULL TIME
WORK SCHEDULE BOTH DIFFICULT AND
COMPLICATED. BANG FOR THOSE
ADDITIONAL HOURS OF CARE CREATED
A BIG FINANCIAL BURDEN TO.
ACCESSING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
GIVES MY CHILD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH CHILDREN
HIS AGE WHICH NURTURES HAS
SOCIAL SKILLS AND BETTER
PREPARES HIM FOR THE SCHOOL. IT
ALSO GIVES FROM THE TIME HE
NEEDS TO ENGAGE IN MEANINGFUL
LEARNING AND PLAY. PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION WILL- GIVE ME
GREATER CONFIDENCE THAT WHEN MY
YOUNGEST HILD TURNS FIVE I WILL
EASILY BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
REACH A LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
THAT MY CHILD NEEDS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THIS COMMITTEE EIGHT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY MANZINI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY CULTURALLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OTHERS. MISS
QUIRK-SILVA OR ANY OPPOSITION
SORRY ANY OPPOSITION. I
APOLOGIZED. GOOD AFTERNOON
JEREMY MEMBERS SECRETARY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION- WE CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION- CSPA HAS LONG BEEN
ADVOCATE FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN- ARE ISSUES WITH
THE ACTUAL USE THE CLASS SIZE
REDUCTIONS AND ALL OF THIS IS
BEEN A LONG STANDING FUND THAT'S
BEEN USED FOR VERY PARTICULAR
PURPOSE OF ANY SCHOOL THE BY OUR
- THIS. MAY CONTENT. IS FOR THEY
CAN IT PRESENT NUMBER. THE
CHALLENGES WE STILL. THE CURRENT
NAY STAFF IN TEACHER SHORTAGE
THAT WE ARE FACING TODAY
FACILITIES ISSUES- AS WELL AS
TRANSPORTATION- CHALLENGES AND
SO ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMEND AMENDMENTS
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEY GO
FAR ENOUGH- WE BELIEVE THAT. A
BETTER APPROACH IS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SEPARATE AND
APART FROM THE USE OF CSR WE
THINK THAT. COMBINED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. THE GOAL FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN WITH CS OUR MEANT
TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE A MUCH MORE
ROBUST KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM
AGAIN- WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THIS MEMBERS LEADERSHIP ON
EXPANDING ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL
EXPAND ACCESS TO CAN GUARD UP.
THE RAMP ARE MAY CONCERN IS THE
USE OF THIS YEAR'S ARSENAL FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PURPOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MEGAN BEAR WITH
THE ASSOCIATION BRINGS
COMMISSIONERS I JUST ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS MAY COLLEAGUES
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION SING
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK.
I'LL JUST MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
I STRUGGLE THIS- I DO BECAUSE-
WE WERE ALTERING LC OF A BIT
HERE I SIZE REDUCTION FORMULA-
REMEMBER WHEN YOU GO TO FULL DAY
YOU'RE PROBABLY TAKING A TEACHER
OUT OF THE CLASSROOM. THE WAY IT
TYPICALLY WORKS NOW. IS THIS IN
MY EXPERIENCE. IS A MIGHT BE
HAVE TAKEN A RIGHT. BUT YOU'LL
HAVE TYPICALLY OF TWO TEACHERS
IN THAT ROOM- DURING THAT-
DURING THAT TIME. ALPHAGO FULL
DAY THERE'S ONLY ONE TEACHER.
THAT'S JUST THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING WE NEED TO. BE
COGNIZANT OF SOMETHING OR
WALKING INTO- THAT I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EFFORTS EIGHT.
YOU MISTER. STUDENTS HAVE MORE
CHALLENGES THAN OTHERS BE
OFFERED THIS OFFER. AS SOON AS
WE CAN GET IT TO THEM THAT'S
KIND OF BUILT INTO THE BILL THE
STAGGERED APPROACH- BUT WITH
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILLS OR ANY. FURTHER CULTURALLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISS
QUIRK-SILVA. I SUPPORT THIS
BILL- A FEW- TRENDS OF LATE
FIRST OF ALL. THE HALF DAY
KINDERGARTEN- WHICH MANY OF US
HAVE OUR OWN CHILDREN AND-
REALLY IS BECOMING SOMETHING OF
THE PAST- AS WE SAID FOR. MORE
AND MORE WORKING WOMEN
PARTICULARLY WHO ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE GETTING THEIR KIDS BACK.
TO SCHOOL TO BE A- YOU. BUT NOT
ONLY- HAVE A HALF DAY AND ONLY
SAY HALF DAY IT'S REALLY. ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE HOURS- SO.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HAVING A
CHILD THAT YOU NEED TO PICK UP
ABOUT ELEVEN THIRTY OR BEFORE
NOON- AND SOME SCHOOLS DO OFFER
AFTER SCHOOL PICK A CARE. BUT
CARE IS OFTEN A CARE THAT HAS TO
BE PAID FOR. BUT ASIDE FROM
THAT. EDUCATION OF ADDITIONAL
HOURS THAT EIGHT KENDER CHILD IS
IN SCHOOL REALLY HAS. AN IMPACT
THAT CAN KEEP UP WITH SOME OF
OUR OTHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
WHERE THEIR THEIR CHARTER
WHETHER THEY'RE- PRIVATE SCHOOLS
BUT- THERE IS MORE AND MORE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT ARE CHOOSING
THEIR NOT BEING MADE TO THEY'VE
CHOSEN TO GO FULL DAY. BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF TODAY'S
EDUCATION SO I SUPPORT THIS.
SITE AS FAR AS THE TEACHER RATIO
UP MYSELF OFTEN TEACHING IN THE
YOUNGER GRADES- SOMETIMES IT'S A
MYTH THAT YOU HAVE TO TEACHERS
IN THERE BECAUSE OF THE DOUBLE
THERE'S ALWAYS. DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT SCHOOL SITE DO DO THIS KIND
OF- INJURY IN IT IT'S NOT THE
FULL THREE HOURS THAT YOU HAVE
TO TEACHER AND THEIR TIME THAT'S
REALLY HALF OF THAT TIME- BUT
THEN LASTLY WHAT I WOULD SAY. IS
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ACCOMMODATING FOR TEACHING PRO
AM- ADDITIONAL SPACE. A. B. IF
THIS IS REALLY PUSH THROUGH OUR
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ACCOMMODATING BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ALSO KNOW WHICH IS
WERE ON A DOWNWARD TREND OF
ENROLLMENT SO THERE ARE GOING TO
BE A CLASSROOMS THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE SCHOOL SIZES
UP REALLY ENROLLMENT CONTINUING
TO GO DOWN NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC BUT BECAUSE OF
THESE LONG TERM TRENDS I THINK
WE ACCOMMODATE THIS AND GET OUR
KINDERGARTENS DOUBLE THE TOP IN
THE CLASS. IT'S ONLY GOING TO
BE- BENEFIT THEM ESPECIALLY FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THANKS
FOR READING THIS TOWARD. GREAT
THANK YOU AND I JUST HOPE THAT
WE'RE NOT LOOKING THIS IS CHILD
CARE WILL ACTUALLY LOOKING AT IT
AS EDUCATION- I'VE HEARD MANY
AND- KINDERGARTEN TEACHER ARGUE
TO ME THEIR PROP TIME IS LONGER
THAN OTHER TEACHERS. BECAUSE THE
VERY TACTILE NATURE OF THE
LEARNING EXPERIENCE THE CUTTING
BETTER OF LETTERS ETCETERA. PREP
TIME THEY HAVE TO DO FOR THEIR
CLASSROOM SO JUST YOU KNOW
DESERVE JUST THINGS WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT AS WE GO FORNOT
OPPOSED TO IT. JUST REALIZE THE
IMPACTS THIS COULD HAVE. ON
TEACHERS ON STUDENTS AS A WHOLE
WOULD AFFECT YOU MISTER MISTER.
YEAH I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
AND I THINK ABOUT THOSE TEACHERS
WHO DO TO. BOSS'S BIRTHDAY
THAT'S A KILLER FOR THOSE
TEACHERS WELL- TEACH ONE CLASS
PER DAY THAT HAVE TO TEACH TO A
DOUBLE CHECK FOR A KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS AND 80% OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ALREADY OFFER THIS WE
THINK. WORKING WITH YOU GERALD
DOT ON YOUR COMMITTEE WE HAVE A
FAIR COMPROMISE THAT IT'S AT
LEAST ONE CLASSROOM PER SCHOOL
AND WE GIVE MULTIPLE YEARS TO
PHASES THEN. WE ARE PROVIDING
MONIES- FOR FACILITIES AND AS
THE MISS QUIRK-SILVA SAID WE
BECAUSE OF DECLINING ENROLLMENT
ALLOTTEES DISTRICTS WILL HAVE.
EXTRA CLASSROOM ANYWAY SO.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT MORE
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTESIN
KINDERGARTEN IN THE NOT BABY
SITTING AT HELP STUDENTS-
SUCCEED IN FIRST GRADE ON LOS
WHAT HELPS. WORKING PARENTS
BECAUSE GOING FOR THREE HOURS WE
CAME OUT IF YOU GOT THE SECOND
SHIFT. TO GO TO KINDERGARTEN AND
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GET A LOT OF.
AND THEN TO PICK UP TOO I HOW
YOU COULD HAVE A BILL TO GO TO
WORK OF. IT'S SUPER BOWL. I
CAN'T- SHIFT FOR- FOR THE PART
DAY- SO THIS IS- AT IT'S A FAIR
COPPER. MANIC POLICY GOING FOR
CAL. RIGHT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- YOU CLOSE SO YEAH WELL
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI THE
DONAL I'D DALLY. VALLEY KNOW
BENNETT. SENATE AYE CHAN. CAN
NOW BE LEAI MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA XLVI. FIVE OF THOSE
FIVE ALSO IT IS A MISTER MCCURRY
. WITH THAT WILL GO TO. AB ERROR
ITEM THIRTEEN WELL I'M THIRTEEN
AB TWO ONE ONE SIX MISTER
MCCARTY AGAIN YEAH I THINK YOU
MISTER SHARE THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA SERVICE ACTS WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS AND CITY.
TO HAVE A MORE ROBUST- SERVICE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
SERVICE LEARNING WE NOW
INTEGRATES ACADEMICS AND HANDS
ON COMMUNITY SERVICE RESEARCH
SHOWS THE POP POSITIVE BENEFITS
AS HAVE ON OUR STUDENTS THIS
WOULD CREATE A PILOT PROJECT
PILOT PROGRAM. THE CALIFORNIA
SERVICE PILOT PRO. CALDERON
TEARS TO MINISTER- THIS PROGRAM-
THIS IS A WIN WIN FOR STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES PROGRAMS ASK
YOUR I DON'T THINK. YOUR FIRST
WITNESS. IT YOUR MIKE BUTTON
THERE. IS THAT WORKING HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDRABI LAW I'M WITH IMPROVE
YOUR TOMORROW WE ARE A NONPROFIT
COLLEGE ACCESS AND PREPARATION
PROGRAM FOR YOUNG MEN OF COLOR
DEDICATING TO INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF YOUNG MEN OF COLOR WHO
ATTENDED GRADUATE COLLEGE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND BEYOND. I
WENT T. IS AN AMERICORPS PROGRAM
MEANING ALL OF OUR MENTORS- ARE
LISTED AS AMERICORPS SERVICE
MEMBERS UNDER CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS AND WE SERVE OVER
THREE THOUSAND. PASTERNS WE'VE
TO EACH MEMBER HAS A BROTHER AND
AS A COLLECTIVE THE BROTHERHOOD
. AND WHEN OUR CLASSROOMS ARE
COUPLED WITH MENTOR OF COLOR
THESE TERMS TEND TO REINFORCE
THE CAMARADERIE AMONGST OUR
BROTHERS AND PROVIDE THEM A
SENSE OF BELONGING PURPOSE AND
IDENTITY. HAVING FELT EXPERIENCE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE POURS
INTO THEM AND HELP US REALIZE
OUR FULL POTENTIAL MANY OF OUR
BROTHERS DECIDED TO BECOME
MENTORS WHEN THEY GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE. THIS LEADS
TO A CYCLE OF BROTHERS WHO WERE
TAUGHT AND I ALREADY CLASSROOMS
WITHIN SERVICE AS A MENTOR.
SUPPORTING THE GENERATIONS THAT
COME AFTER THEM. MENTORS ARE
GIVING BACK TO THE BROTHERHOOD.
THEY ARE SENSUALLY GIVING BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY. THE STUDY A
PILOT PROGRAM A. B. TWO ONE ONE
SIX WILL PROVIDE WITH THE
COLLABORATION AND LEADERSHIP OF
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND CAL LONG TEARS
WILL REPLICATE AND BUILD UPON
THE SUCCESS I Y. T. HAS SEEN
WITH ITS YOUTH AN UNBEATEN IN
OTHER UNDERSERVED AREAS ACROSS
THE STATE. WITH INTEGRATED
CONTINI ORIENTED SERVER RUNNING
PROGRAMS IN HIGH SCHOOLS.
PARTICIPATING SENIORS WILL HAVE
INCREASED CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
ABILITIES TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS. IMPROVED ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND BECOME MORE
CIVICALLY ENGAGED. WHEN THIS
HAPPENS NOT ONLY DO STUDENTS AND
SCHOOLS THRIVE ASSERTED THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WE WANT TO THANK
ASSIGNMENT FOR MCCARTY FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
AND PASS THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
THE ANY ANY. THE PERSON WHO WISH
TO SHOW THEIR SUPPORT IMPORTS
SAME IN ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SO YOU KNOW OPPOSITION
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY. LEE AND
SECONDED BY MISTER ALI-
MENDOCINO CONSERVE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH I
THINK YOU HAD I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE BY SAYING HOW MUCH- WE
KNOW SERVICE LEARNING MATTERS
IT. THEN AYE AYE I WANNA THANK
YOU. MISTER O'DONNELL PATRICK
FOR- FOCUSING ON WE DON'T WANT
THIS TO GO TO THE KIDS WHO HAVE
ALREADY HAD THEIR YOU KNOW
APPLICATION TO GO TO UCLA SHOULD
BE FOCUSED ON SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
HAVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES HELP I
THINK ONE OF THE GOOD
SUGGESTIONS AND HERE'S FOCUSING
ON- THE SCHOOLS WHO NEED THE
MOST AMOUNT OF HELP AND PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT SENSE OF THIS TO BE
GOOD FOR KIDS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WITH THAT ASKED RIGHT BUT- WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OUT ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY ONE SIXTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. O'DONNELL
I'VE DONE ALL I DALY. SALLY I
BENNETT. SENATE I CHEN. I
BELIEVE HE BY MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I.
ALSO VOTED IS OUT SO THAT- WE
NEED TO MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FIRST. AND CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED. CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB TWO ZERO FOUR FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI THE DONALD I. DALY
HI SALLY I'D BENNETT. BENNETT I
CHEN. CHEN I LEE. LEVY I MCCARTY
. MCCARTY AYE QUIRK-SILVA BURKE
SURVIVE YES SEVEN VOTE SERVICE
OUT WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO THE
TO THE CALLS I BELIEVE. WE'LL
JUST GO THROUGH EACH BILL. FILE
ITEM ONE AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I. CAN. CHEN NO
LEAVE THE I. QUIRK-SILVA. BURKE
SURVIVE. WE HAVE FIVE OF THOSE
FIVE VOTES. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB NINETEEN FORTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I. EIGHT LEAI
QUIRK-SILVA BURKE SURVIVE YEAH.
THAT'S FIVE VOTES IT IS ON. FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DONALD AYE
O'DONNELL AYE SENATE AND IT AYE
CHAN CHAN NO LEAKS LEAI. IT HAS
FIVE ALSO IS ON SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
EIGHTY TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF DONALD HI
DONALD FIVE SENATE. SENATE I
CHEN CHEN AYE LEE LEAVE AYE
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I'VE AS
SEVEN VOTES SO THAT IS OUT TO
SOME SIMPLE. SO FAR FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWO NINE THREE THREE
WE NEED TO MIGHT AS WELL MOVE I
MESSED UP EARLY. THE SECOND. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL HIGH DELHI DELHI
IDENTIT. SENATE AYE CHAN CHAN I
. LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I'D THIS
THE BILL SOME LOADED IS OUT. WE
GET YEAH RIGHT. WE WILL BEFORE I
DO I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK ON ALL THESE BILLS. TO
SEE IF YOUR BILL LIVED THEY DID
YOU A FAVOR OF IT DIED YOU DID
THEY DID YOU A FAVOR SO WITH
THAT I THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ALL OF THEM- AND
FOR THEIR HARD WORK THEIR HOURS
THEIR WEEKENDS THEIR PHONE CALLS
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AS-
THEY DIDN'T THEY THEY SPEND A
LOT. OF THESE BILLS SO THANK
THANK THANK THANK YOU ALL. FOR
THAT THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED-
THE ROLE IS OPEN FOR ADAMS SO.
AT. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IT'S AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY FIVE SENATE. SENATE I LI.
LI AYE QUIRK-SILVA. BURKE
SURVIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I AM. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT PROMOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEAD.
LEAI QUIRK-SILVA BURKE SURVIVE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO
ZERO FOUR TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHEN. THE LEAD.
NUMBER EIGHT LEAI. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LI LI
AYE QUIRK-SILVA. BURKE SURVIVED.
ALL RIGHT. NOW.